on est reparti le Fab tu m'entends
toujours ouais parfaitement yo le Fab
alors attendez les amis je vais aller
chercher les caméras du match je vais
mettre le truc le truc en place on a
pris le maximum de temps pour pouvoir
voir les la partie en Espagne de Baki je
sais pas si si tu as pu jeter un œil le
Fab
mec aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est pas les recover ouais
mais il nous a montré sa partie contre
Paco Valero juste avant ouais ok non
mais j'ai pas vu la partie mais j'ai pas
j'ai pas vu le stream Babel partie
écoute
belle partie belle victoire de Baki ça
faisait longtemps qu'il y avait pas
battu en 2007 plus en longue
mais je crois qu'il fait un mauvais
tournoi non pas qu'on va aller rote son
côté
j'ai vu qu'il est perdu notre partie
voilà je sais pas trop ce qu'il fait
mais après même un joueur comme ça quand
il joue pas super bien ça reste pas
simple à battre quand même
ouais je te confirme non non mais
pas ça pour minimiser la performance de
base
c'est pas facile en plus ce premier en
se tournant il est fort
la Ligue de honneur toi tu joues en
Ligue 2 c'est ça en Espagne vous savez
on est monté en Ligue 2 honneur donc bon
ça donne pas très envie quoi mais tu vas
jouer l'an prochain je sais pas je leur
conseille pas mais ils font comme ils
veulent
non mais basiquement en fait le truc
c'est que tu as le droit qu'à trois
étrangers
et quitte à prendre l'étranger ils
pourront trouver mieux que moi quand
même quoi donc je veux dire c'est pour
leur bien que c'est mieux de prendre
quelqu'un de plus fort que moi après bah
quitte à prendre personne je suis quand
même mieux que leur genre locaux au pire
mais
bon
ouais
c'est pas c'est pas idéal quoi non mais
je pense que le président Yoko mais en
fait le club là dans lequel je suis
c'est un club récent ils sont montés
cinq fois en 5 ans le truc n'existait
pas il y a 6 ans et là ils sont en
Division d'Honneur donc donc c'est bon
quoi enfin donc après bon à un moment ça
va être un peu plus dur quoi ils vont
pas non plus de champion l'an prochain
ça peut pas monter comme ça comme des
fusées en permanence mais c'est déjà
c'est déjà très bien donc donc écoute on
verra s'il faut un peu à moi peut-être
que je viendrai jouer un peu comme cette
année tu vois j'ai fait deux rondes à la
fin parce que bon voilà ils avaient
besoin un peu mais je m'attends pas à
jouer toute la ligue et puis bah s'il
trouve un des recrues bah ça sera même
mieux pour eux
c'est c'est vu le niveau il faut il faut
avoir du 2006-2007 en étranger
on met tout en place on va rajouter les
caméras des joueurs le match normalement
il est bon aussi ce que je veux dire
c'est que là même en des deux on avait
polo Mario qui Gorian ou le premier quoi
genre moi j'étais au 3 enfin pas tout le
long comme je t'ai dit mais et après on
avait en féminine ok
2400 je sais pas quoi 10 on va dire
on avait un autre jour à 2004 et un
dernier 2004 donc ça c'est juste la
deuxième division et avec ça c'est sûr
que tu te maintiens pas normalement
enfin en tout cas
en première je veux dire en deuxième tu
montres où tu peux monter c'était pas
fait d'avance mais ouais on y arrive
ouais en deuxième division
en première division c'est quoi
bon c'est chaud tu vois enfin quand je
regarde le la compo de l'équipe de Baki
la Torah baquis pour nos Maria Fenay
et après tu as 2004 qui joue les uns et
d'autres donc on a une équipe du niveau
de salle de backi mais ils sont dernier
donc c'est chaud quand on va être donc
ils peuvent se maintenir ou quoi mais
c'est tendu
on va mettre les caméras je me demande
si le match est parti je vais devoir les
recouper comme d'habitude mais en fait
ce que j'ai un bug ou pas parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'ils sont en train de
jouer FAP c'est pour ça que tu m'entends
mais bon je suis Maxime dans c'est bon
on va pouvoir ajuster les cames
normale ou ouais normalement il a le
droit par contre on a plus de rose
écouteurs
alors ça c'est une autre question mais
il a le droit
je règle juste la cam parce que comme
toujours ça arrive au dernier moment
donc on veut pas le faire en amont
mais ça va aller et au moins on va
pouvoir se délecter du match donc
continue avec ses ouvertures
donc c'est trop c'est moins pire que
d'autres coups débiles mais
de toute façon c'était sûr qu'il
continuerait dans ces de cette acabit
mais je pense pas qu'il rejoue des trucs
complètement
fous quoi contre Maxime
non bah là en fait
c'est comme une scandinave avec deux
cahiers C3 des 4 qui est ici ce qui est
G3 quoi ouais alors moi je la joue un
peu cette position mais le truc c'est
que je vous donne des cinq quoi
mais non ça va complètement t'as même
des plans avec H5 H4 qui peuvent exister
pour aller sans prendre aux cavaliers
rapidement
donc ouais c'est une position
complètement correcte alors attends on
n'a pas les deux pendules
je me disais qu'il y avait un truc qui
allait pas c'est pour ça que tu me
sentais hésitant mais tu peux la mettre
au dessus non mais c'est bon
tu me demandais ça puis en même temps
que te répondre j'étais en train de dire
il y a un truc qui va pas et comme les
matchs sont longs on prend on prend un
peu le temps les amis pour la première
partie de toute façon vous allez avoir 4
heures de match donc j'ai envie de dire
c'est ça ça a pas joué dans les
premières secondes c'est pas c'est pas
là que ça se joue
mais je sais que Maxime on sait pas mal
parlé les derniers jours il est très
très près il est prêt sur un petit peu
tout au premier coup il est prêt à en
découdre
plutôt très bien ces temps-ci et donc
bah écoute s'il y a bien un moment une
année on peut le faire
surtout que nous on sera vendredi en
direct pour suivre la fier enfin je sais
pas si tu seras là d'ailleurs Fab
vendredi pour mais
peut-être en tout cas en tout cas moi je
serai à Paris à lispot entrée libre un
vendredi soir on vous reconfirmera
l'horaire enfin à moins qu'il nous mette
un comme il change d'horaire assez
souvent qu'on a un horaire bizarre mais
sinon on sera ensemble normalement à
partir de 19h vendredi à Paris donc en
très libre vous pourrez venir suivre le
stream et le match en notre compagnie et
profiter aussi du bar enfin parce que
toi je crois que si tu viens c'est pas
pour commenter mais c'est pour suivre le
match et surtout que profiter du bar
de qualité non mais l'endroit est sympa
en fait
non mais en fait sûrement que je sois au
dernier moment mais si je peux je
viendrai et au cas où je serai là pour
la somme battle de toute façon ça c'est
acté ça je raterai pour rien au monde
parce que tu as le savent aussi quand
même avec avec le foot on a tous le
sable
manière exactement donc cette position
écoute elle paraît parfaite pour Maxime
il va mettre les tours au centre
ça se passe bien bon ça se passe très
bien
bon ok il a reculé une petite pression
sur le full 6 quand même
qui veut taper 7 bon on va voir mais
est-ce que est-ce que c'est vraiment
l'air sur FF5 Jordan D6 après j'ai du
mal à dire ouais
ça marche pour nous quoi sinon c'est
contre faire double les pions aussi quoi
ouais mais ça a une tête d'un truc qui
marche je suis Maxime la jouer
si ça marchait pas Maxime Le jouerai pas
ça peut être une idée tu vois genre
je t'aime mon frère G5
mais là ça peut juste bien se passer ce
qu'on peut faire trois C8 au prochain
s'il est blanc fondaient 3 se fait des
trous un peu sur les cases noires
ça a l'air ok ça a l'air et donc ça a
l'air de passer comme moi cette année
sur mon premier match au commentaire
dans ce speech
c'est quoi le format enfin je sais
comment ça c'est 5 + 1 3 + 1 + 1 mais en
temps de jeu
entente jeu c'est 1h30 alors ça va être
écrit en dessous regarde sur sur l'écran
alors là il te rappelle un petit peu
toutes les toutes les toutes les règles
en cas d'égalité totale tu auras quatre
parties en plus un
mais oui c'est 1h30 de 5 + 5 1h de 3 + 1
et une demi-heure deux un plus un
donc donc ce sera un match
long il vaut mieux bien commencer
surtout kikaro est censé être fort en
belette en tout cas sur sur ce que
montre Maxime depuis quelques semaines
ça me paraît ça me paraît complètement
faisable sur toute la cette parcelle se
passe vraiment bien je trouve
mais en fait peut-être qu'il a enfin pas
trop le choix dans le sens où
normalement ça allait mal se passer et
il a senti qu'il devait [__] le bordel
et tenter un truc mais ça a l'air hyper
risqué ça par quoi
ouais ça a l'air risqué là je me demande
si tu fais tout rabb8 attaques le fou si
tu pars pour cavalier G4 il a peut-être
dame F3
et juste voilà
mais on peut juste jouer tour à B8 sinon
surtout quand en plus elle peut sauter
en B5 peut-être et partir là-bas
pour protéger et là peut-être on peut
juste bouffer un truc non voilà je
comprends des deux
moi je dirais pourquoi pas prendre des
deux ça m'a l'air
clairement à l'heure actuelle on a que
un tournoi
pas mal de jeux Le Fou B2 bon il fait
pas trop peur
donc
écoute ça va et donc d'un F3 là me prend
les deux juste on récupère le pion de
moins avec plutôt une meilleure
structure et on menace en plus de
récupérer ses deux un derrière
ça nous mettrez tellement bien de
commencer par une victoire je pense que
c'est relativement important Fab de
commencer fort
la course derrière mettre un petit doute
à carreau et puis et puis on verra lui
mettre un petit impact sous la sous la
casquette
et donc la finale sera contre Magnus
Carlsen qui s'est imposé hier avec une
immense facilité pour ceux qui ont suivi
le match c'était plié après 40 minutes
de jeu et
pour te donner un exemple Fab sur sur le
scénario du match après à la mi-temps du
3 + 1 donc à la moitié de la deuxième
portion de match donc à moitié à
mi-match en fait il y avait je crois 11
et demi à deux et demi non mais je sais
qu'il
la piétinait ouais pour l'instant
Carlson il se balade dans le tournoi
Espagne un peu trop quoi c'est trop
violent quoi après en ce qui concerne ça
quand même pour qui c'est quand même
fait vraiment marché dessus
petite chose rassurante pour lui c'est
qu'il joue un autre tournoi en même
temps et je le title c'est ça non il
jouait il joue un truc en Allemagne il
joue l'Armageddon je sais pas quoi au
tournoi fluide de Blitz ou quoi donc tu
vois il est en duplex de tournoi d'échec
quoi donc c'est ce que je disais hier
pendant live c'est qu'il y a maintenant
tellement de tournois d'échecs tout au
long de l'année que les joueurs de
niveau joue carrément plusieurs tournois
en même temps quoi donc c'est
voilà tu peux pas il a pas pu quoi mais
non mais en fait basiquement même moi je
tenais de le faire quoi
tu joues ou tu joues pas quoi mais c'est
comme ça quoi les règles étaient-elles
que voilà
de toute façon il laisse faire au genre
ce qu'ils veulent quoi mais mais je sais
pas tu vas pas ça
quoi tu vas pas jouer à un tournoi un
Master 1000 et en même temps de
challenger à côté de je sais pas quoi
enfin c'est toujours ton truc quoi
ça va bouffer
et donc oui il a bien fait le plan avec
la tour sur la 5e et bon ça a l'air
pourri pour les rois pour les blancs
pendant après le roi oui il veut aller
se cacher comme tu as fait les flèches
il y a peut-être pas se faire mater trop
vite mais bon il est
il défend quoi même quand il est très
très mal
il se laisse pas perdre comme ça donc
c'est pas fait mais superposition quoi
je peux je peux pas tout dire mais je
peux te dire qu'il y a eu un
entraînement spécifique de la part de
Maxime justement pour pour être plus en
capacité de terminer les parties contre
des adversaires qui défendent très très
bien
il y a eu un petit entraînement très
spécial ouais je crois que tu as compris
la spécialité de l'entraînement il s'est
entraîné avec quelqu'un qui défend le
très bien quoi c'est ça c'est entraîné
contre du très gros défenseur justement
pour pour être en capacité de terminer
les parties contre on espère que que ça
permette un maximum de terminer
d'ailleurs tu vois là il prend bien son
temps à Maxime il a vraiment décidé de
de pas laisser s'enfuir et de réussir à
le fermer le maximum je trouve ça
d'ailleurs
d'accord il fait foi 6
x 3 pardon il contre-attaque je sais pas
quoi je savais pas foi
ça va être une prise c'est gagné let's
go let's go le Fab c'est le premier
Punto qui tombe bah il fait il fait du
bien celui-là non
bonne partie juste bien gagner quoi et
bien mérité donc on va voir allez 1-0 le
match est très très long les amis il
faut pas faut pas s'enflammer là faut
pas s'enflammer tout de suite il faut
prendre les parties les unes après les
autres enchaînées on sait qui Caro il a
un mode Turbo il peut te faire très très
mal Maxime il a déjà eu à subir le
courroux du joueur américain un point
c'est rien on va essayer là de confirmer
ce mini break et et faire un premier
petit écart dans ce match Fab
vaut mieux être plus simple à -1
évidemment évidemment mais tu sais que
je suis très inquiet lorsque les matchs
sont contre le Diable qui est ikaruna
camera donc je ne veux pas me faire de
fausses joie d'entrée
non non mais c'est juste bien quoi voilà
et puis peut-être on va voir si il
continue à jouer ces trois et compagnie
dans les prochaines parties quoi
je peux te dire que Maxime m'a annoncé
avant il me battrapa avec cavaliste C3
A3 H3 et compagnie il m'a dit ok Simba
et qui fait ça vu la forme que j'ai il
m'a dit tu sauras
il m'a dit non ça passera pas ça passera
pas contre moi et il a trouvé dans la
première partie
que ça ne passait pas
et il va très très très vite revenir à
des ouvertures normales le Hikaru
normal sans aucune prépa sans rien
il va être préparé il va être préparé je
pense pas qu'il puisse se [__] de la
gueule ouvertement de Maxime comme il a
pu le faire avec d'autres joueurs il va
être rappelé à quelques bases quand même
à mon avis
bon allez il faut il faut réussir à
mettre la pression sur ce pion sur ce
pion C6 blanche
il y a plusieurs atouts qui est faible
faut dire aussi que le fou G7 quand on
est enceinte kéto avec les Blancs à
faire se décape 5 c'est toujours un peu
problématique donc des fois ils essayent
de faire F6 ou quoi mais tu es pas
obligé de toucher et puis quoi qu'il en
soit ça crée de nouveau trop bon tu vois
il essaye parce que tu dois t'activer
les Noirs en fait mais c'est pas trop
inquiétant et donc je me dis que là
peut-être qu'elle est B3 c'est logique
tu peux aussi peut-être faire bêtement
il a fait H3 pour paquet de Fougères ça
rajoute pas de pression sur le centre
bah logique aussi
donc
ce qui m'ont aussi très heureux Fab
c'est la pendule de Maxime pour le
moment
ouais ouais c'est tu vois c'est le
Maxime que j'ai que je trouve là depuis
un mois qui joue vite qui joue bien qui
joue précis tu vois c'est on le retrouve
là Maxime c'est quand même assez assez
incroyable on l'a perdu pendant plus
d'un an
et on la retrouvait
c'était peut-être Maxime pas chier pas
chier pas grave mon Fab pendant pendant
quelques années et là on a retrouvé le
vrai
mais tant mieux
il a joué G5 donc il tente une attaque
ouais mais c'est ouais ça a l'air un peu
bidon dans ce qui fait la Camille Caron
on va pas se mentir oui non mais
clairement mieux pour les blancs après
après voilà il va essayer d'embarquer sa
dame vers G6 H5 faire KF4 du G4 des
bidouilles quoi mais oui tu as cette
position en partie
lentement
plus que plus 004 mais franchement enfin
c'est pas des coups là qui joue non bah
je sais pas
ce que je te dis enfin il peut pas faire
grand-chose il se fait juste bouffer
stratégiquement dans leur position si tu
fais rien donc il a raison de jouer
comme ça pour le coup là
oui oui non mais très certainement mais
genre c'est ça veut dire plus sur sa
position que qu'autre chose quoi oui
on demande quand vous voyez cette
expérience c'est mauvais bah je sais pas
tu peux pas avoir un [__] non mais tu
peux avoir tes pièces comme ça avec les
Noirs ça t'as pas de pions au centre
enfin tant pis il est en E7 je sais pas
tu pousses des pions comme ça tu as le
fond j'ai 7 qui est zarbile qui va lui
aussi s'il a pas vraiment de rebond ça
peut pas aller en fait
arnaquer et bon ça tombe jamais mais
là j'adore
tu peux tu peux décaler avec toi après
ça peut faire mal
c'est pas si évident enfin c'est jouable
c'est pas le coup le plus dur de l'année
mais
cavaliers à 5 des conneries comme ça
quoi peut-être pas le plus précis Fab ça
a enlevé un problème de la position à
Ikaru quand même
ça réactive un peu la dame c'est un peu
dommage c'est la première couche je
dirais de ce qu'on va du match de Maxime
où je me dis ah là c'est
premier plutôt dommage
pour moi après avec mon niveau
pourri mais ça c'est le premier coup je
me dis pas waouh tu as encore un énième
coup de génie de Maxime quoi
bonhomme de trois j'aime bien en gros il
veut je pense éviter G4 enfin il y a le
droit de le faire mais tu veux bouffer
qu'il y a H4 et tu as des cases en F5 G6
donc donc c'est plutôt logique ce qui
fait un maximum
ouais je sais pas s'il peut jouer un
coup comme à 5 pour
5 à 4 x 6 mais bon ça a pas l'air ouf
avec les Blancs enfin moi j'aime pas
encore pression
il caresse c'est à dire que il est pas
bien mais t'as rien de plus et il a
enfin il a pas vraiment de faiblesse il
a pas de faiblesse tout sable facilement
ou gagnable facilement en fait
[Musique]
nous on aurait aucun plan et lui il va
réussir à te bidouiller un truc je pense
qu'il va faire tout ces deux-là maximum
ou c'est 3c2 je sais pas laquelle qui
veut mais
moi
il provoque G4
[Musique]
mais oui on a eu la même
intuition logique donc il veut revenir
vers G3 et taper F5 H5
là la position de Maxime elle est
magnifique tour B7 cavalier F1 non bah
ouais
on va déjà poser une première base
Dame des deux
bon pourquoi je sais pas pourquoi
à mon avis
à mon avis c'est ça il va faire la
double la double prise du sommeil sur
sur le pur H5
je sais pas j'ai envoyé ça au hasard
mais je le vois bien libérer la case
pour un pour un cheval peut-être tenter
non mais ça marche pas je vais dire F5
F4 mais en fait F5 comme tu as kg 3 F4
vous prend il y a pas de tour 2 donc
très bien quelle est la terre en J3
voilà bon écoute c'est tout est logique
et l'autre arrive
pour l'instant c'est très bien est-ce
que ça s'appellerait pas un cours
d'échec pour le moment mon Fab cette
partie de Maxime
attention Hikaru il va falloir envoyer
envoyer la caillasse qui va prendre au
speechs là pour pour le cours
parce que là s'il est en train de lui
faire une master piste stratégique mon
Fab pas piqué des hannetons notre Maxime
et un joueur plus ou moins lambda mon
Fab n'ayant pas peur des mots
voilà c'est c'est un récital pour le
moment de Maxime
oh il a pas l'air bien quand même
ben c'est toujours aussi dur à jouer
pour lui sa position face à rien de
s'améliore il a poussé ses pions mais
comme d'hab c'est les pions ça laisse
des trous et ça revient pas en arrière
donc
maintenant
6 ça s'appelle un punto il va ramener le
Cavaillon F4 il va nous jouer du BK4 il
va nous mettre le pion à 3 et après on
va voir il peut plus bouger il caroube
alors est-ce que tu tentes fou F4 en
disant de tête il va pas avoir fouder 6
non je pense que ça il l'aurait quand
même il voit un peu trop de choses quoi
ça c'est ça
mais
non mais ok j'aimerais bien que cette
partie soit gagnée aussi
mais pour pour le principe quoi c'est
juste qu'il y a un joueur qui joue aux
échecs dans cette partie il y en a un
autre qui joue c'est un joueur de café
avec les Noirs mon Fab n'ayant pas peur
des mots
n'ayons pas peur des mots
il a pas l'air bien quand même
pour le moment il est concentré Maxime
qui reste très très calme il connaît la
difficulté et l'ampleur des travaux qui
lui reste à faire pour pour emporter ce
match
il faut le maintenir dans ces 22 mètres
Fab l'étouffait
on laisse pas sortir ouais faut pas le
laisser sortir il est dangereux quand il
sort de sa cage il faut lui laisser bien
enfermer là il y a pas de il y a pas de
marlouterie il y a pas d'idée tactique
il y a rien tu le sens très empruntéro
ouais
4 quoi est-ce qu'on peut pas juste le
fermer en fait peut-être
dégoûté d'être là quoi
ma vie quoi
[Rires]
qui a aidé trois fois F4 qui avait lieu
5 tu vois et
genre petit à petit
par contre là je suis pas content de la
gestion du temps je suis inquiet
cavalier de jouer attention à plus de 20
secondes c'est là que Hikaru peut se
réveiller tel un loup-garou c'est plus
simple c'est ça ouais c'est plus simple
mais plus simple c'est bien c'est bien
maigre Fab
ouais bien sûr ça t'évite de tomber mais
tu remontes pas trop quoi aller à 4 il
va il va aller fixer là-bas aussi allez
peut-être un petit coup de G3 ça mange
pas de pain dame B2 ça consolide
allez un petit coup de B5 qui rentre
Maxime c'est le plan de Fab ça peut pas
être mauvais
un petit échange assez logique on met
l'autre cavalier après ok il préfère
manger il adore manger les pions Maxime
il a probablement raison
c'est pris le cavalier qui va revenir en
F4 et on va peut-être avoir une finale
probablement
c'est Chao ça ça s'appelle un clouage oh
il a pas l'air bien il Caro oh il a pas
l'air bien sur la vidéo oh ça joue quoi
trois
deuxième mais ouais mais bon ça ça
existe non mais ça c'est typique ouais
mais là là ça fait le malin c'est auprès
de sa communauté ouais cavalier à trois
machin je suis en train de trop là c'est
complètement théorique comme coup assez
petit de la part des carreaux ça essaie
de faire le dur mais ça fait plus dur du
tout en fait mon Fab déjà oh il est en
train de mourir là il Caro
ah il a pas l'air bien
il faut pas s'emballer il faut pas
s'emballer
non mais très bonne partie la première
après là bon écoute on va voir ça
ressemble à bravo c'est une position
dans la piscine avec un camion à 3 et ça
arrive qu'ils airas 3 et donc bon ça va
être une potion plus normale que ce
qu'on a vu avant oui mais bon il veut te
faire passer ça pour une tu vois ce que
je veux dire c'est mon collègue avec
Vadim ah bah ouais c'est et puis à
Christian aussi donc il joue ça ouais
alors bon après tu peux pas le jeu tout
le temps tout le temps mais
[Musique]
des petites mimiques de la tête là il
est en train de faire des petits noms
ouais bon ouais voilà bon ok mais ça
c'est une position normale on a aucun
problème avec les Noirs mais on a
tout de suite peut-être la fable
importance c'est de surtout surtout ne
jamais baisser le régime c'est vraiment
à mon avis
un petit péché mignon on va dire Maxime
c'est des fois les baisses de
concentration
les langues faut maintenir ça tout le
long quoi alors après il a vraiment fait
l'effort contre NiAl Sarine et contre
gokash il a vraiment maintenu la
pression tout au long du match il a eu
beaucoup moins c'est ces petites pertes
de concentration là il a il a on sent
qu'il a travaillé dessus maintenant
évidemment
Ikaru c'est pas Sarine c'est pas Google
non mais bon
c'est pas iron c'est pas c'est pas
vailla de Lead c'est pas le PSG en Ligue
des Champions c'est quand même un peu
plus fort quoi
mettre un peu plus un peu plus un peu
plus méfiant mais bon là il a
complètement égalisé en tout cas
donc oui je me pose questionner sur E5
mais il a choisi plutôt mettre le fou
sur le diagonale bah c'est très bien en
plus il gèle le fouet fin pour le
développement et il a pas toujours pu
tomber donc ça évite quand tu fais
baisser 5 de te prendre des A4 ou quoi
parce que ça peut exister B5 pour le
même genre d'idée mais ta structure est
plus fragile ok donc grand ok
tu attends jouer aux échecs frère
j'ai tellement envie de Maxime le
pulvérise
je pense qu'il faut qu'il le pulvérise
disons il veut que le fou reste en fuite
mais non tu peux faire voilà bah 5 et
essayer de glisser la tour tu fais H4 et
tu vois pas où tu passes quoi tu passes
par rapport 8 il sera très bien puis en
plus regarde on va avoir un petit bonus
on va menacer H3 quand même c'est-à-dire
qu'on va lui on va on va faire ça je
crois parce que sinon on rentre
et le fou F1 il va avoir du mal à sortir
il a besoin de sa dame en H3 mais c'est
vraiment jeu mais ouais si tu repars
là-bas il y a un truc qui qui a l'air
bizarre ouais je crois H4
tu menaçage 3 tours H5 enfin ça enchaîne
hein alors E5 ok
bah peut-être très bien j'en sais rien
il veut juste jouer pour faux cette rock
non
tu peux aussi
il joue ce plan et peut-être
juste rock en fait ouais
c'est bien joué ça de la part du
carreaux quand même
quoi que est-ce qu'on peut faire ranger
deux tours géant
et dames c'est si il commence par tour
D8 j'aime bien de façon tourner 8
intermédiaires on lui glisse et dames tu
veux fous prends G2 tours géant dame
Cécile et tu auras des fous 4 en plus
pourquoi pas je sais pas bon H4 c'est
logique bref ton pion attaqué tu le
défends tu auras des H3 à tout moment
pour aller à la finale maintenant on va
se retenir un peu pendant quelques coups
mais
c'est pas bien payé à mon avis ça aurait
dû enfin Maxime il a bien joué mais je
veux dire Hikaru il est bien payé ça
aurait pu être plus grave
mais bon peut-être que là on a des ou
pas
mais bon ça passe pas trop je crois pas
en tout cas
j'ai essayé de faire marcher aussi mes
pions F3
[Musique]
F3 fouger 5 faut ranger 5 dames frangin
tour des deux
qu'est-ce que c'est bien joué de la part
de Maxime il fait toujours marcher les
coups les plus directs il lui fait mal
là mon Fab
disons ok
ça c'est le coup qu'on a envie de faire
dans la position après
après en capacité de le calcul est
Maxime plus que nous je jette un petit
coup d'œil à la tête du carreaux il a
pas l'air bien
c'est la ligne voilà c'est facile après
un calculer une fois qu'on l'a voilà
c'est ça les rois B1 bouffe et tour des
deux ou dame 3
après il faudrait que sur case noire on
est
on a beaucoup contrôle encore une fois
on va se balader à droite à gauche
c'était évident et comme ligne et après
faut avoir la puissance pour la calculer
quoi mais c'est vrai que sinon elle est
pas super pas super difficile
je peux te dire qui carouille il est il
a la tête sous l'eau il a pas la tête
des bons joueurs
[Musique]
je suis encore avec les Blancs
étourd des deux donc a priori ouais bon
c'est la position dont je vous parlais
tout à l'heure pour pour les quelques
les quelques personnes qui ont pas pu
suivre et je pense dame 3 qui menaçant
[Musique]
une belle pression
après je sais pas si ça suffit c'est une
autre histoire mais bon après on veut
une fois qu'on est comme ça on peut
peut-être partir avec l'autre pion à 5 à
4 à 3
j'aime bien la gestion du temps de
Maxime ça il remet il remet sa tête
entre les mains il calcule à fond il est
éternu un petit coup il est il est dans
sa routine mon Maxime il est concentré à
200% et c'est hikao qui fait des des
petits gestes d'énervement de la tête ah
il a pas l'air bien et peut-être H3
aussi c'est un coup non
maintenant
[Musique]
et en fait
on n'a pas accompli grand chose
ok je crois faut qu'on garde alors
peut-être dans Notre Dame des trois
donc je crois qu'il doit prendre j'ai
pas vu de drame pour lui si il prend
enfin l'autre côté il va récupérer H2 en
Maxime
et du coup tu attaque le fou F3 tata 3
tu as toujours eu 4 un peu fragile
Maxime il joue vraiment à chacun des
coups de Maxime sur chaque choix
compliqué Maxime il prend toujours le
choix le plus agressif de la position
pour le moment dans ce match il y a pas
un moment où il a joué un coup un peu un
peu plus tranquille il a vraiment décidé
de prendre la gorge ce soir
bon c'est son style c'est son style
3 je suppose
en tout cas il lui fait mal ça fait
plaisir mais on ne s'emballe pas pour le
moment mon Fab encore
vraiment on va pas tuer la peau de
l'ours avant de la tuer ok non
la peau de l'ours ne sera pas tué ici
elle sera peut-être vendue Fab mais pas
tu es
un Dame des trois rois c'est la variante
dont on parlait nous on pense à toi
c'est exactement ça
c'est compliqué là il y a tout re trois
encore
mais bon les pièces blanches sont
bizarrement placées on voit le roi un
peu un peu aux abois là-bas il a un pion
plus il carou mais les pions sont quand
même relativement faibles ce foie F3 il
est sous une pression quand même ça
c'est plutôt positif pour Maxime il y a
cette première rangée aussi qui semble
un petit peu faible et si on prend
c'est dur à tenir en fait genre de
position
et des trucs chaque coup
c'est chiant en fait vraiment pénible
c'est très très pénible
en difficulté et Caro
et bien sûr si on prend le pion h après
toutes les finales sont sympas parce
qu'elles piongées ils partent beaucoup
plus vite la majorité des noirs que la
majorité
allait le dame pour les blancs donc tous
deux trois probablement
je sais pas si c'est ces quatre ou cinq
mais
sûrement B5 pour pouvoir retourner vers
G5 ou E5
aussi mais
allez faut pas prendre trop trop de
temps côté Maxime c'est plus facile à
dire qu'à faire évidemment plus en B5 tu
as un petit bonus c'est que tu
commences par tous
ok peut-être dame 5 confits
peut-être un jour des F5
ça joue en combat de rue à la fin
quelques secondes à la pendule il attend
absolument
quand même
mais bon peut-être que Maxime il aime
bien quand même qu'elle visse c'est
quasiment
alors attention de pas se prendre un
dame D8 dame D4 dame prend prise oh il y
a [__] mais oui let's go allez Fab
mais maintenant les puntos qui partent
il secoue il fait que de secouer là et
du coup bah c'est une excellent
puis on passait etc il fallait manger le
Punto va lui manger le Punto mon Maxime
prends-lui tout il va tout comprendre et
après on prend ouais c'est ça on le fixe
quand même
allez roi E5 et
moi aussi
3 secondes pour les carreaux et quoi
trop
faire F3 mais bon Maxime c'est évident
on pénètre et ça fait trois zéro mon Fab
il est où il est où il Caro bah on
m'annonçait on m'a annoncé la grêle pour
Maxime dans ce début de match avec icaru
moi je le cherche Fab oh il est pas il
est pas impressionnant quand il a plus
le cas sur les oreilles car où le
changement de règle qui a fait mal là de
dernière minute mon Fab
c'est moins fort et ça fait mal côté
Maxime
ouais ça fait ça fait trois heures
[Musique]
ramenez-nous des vrais joueurs là
ramenez-nous des vrais joueurs enlever
les peintres là dans ce speech
ça ça réceptionne pas les ballons ça
fait que des en avant pour le moment
Maxime je le vois sur l'écran de
contrôle qui a failli jouer H3 il s'est
ravisé pour le moment et il le fait
finalement j'ai 5 tours C3 c'était quand
même bien passé
ouais bah écoute moi je dois de la même
manière ça aille carreaux de prouver de
montrer ce qu'il a en stock pour tenir
la position parce que la partie d'avant
enfin il y a deux parties quoi la
dernière avec les Blancs elle avait été
assez convaincante j'ai envie de dire
cte non mais bon ok mais c'est trop
bizarre là ce qu'il fait je suis désolé
il faut avancent
quand même assez particulier là
bah écoute
tu as trouvé une fois que tu as fait G5
tu es là pour ça quoi enfin j'ai 5 G4
faut prendre G4 se détruire le rock
comme ça c'est quand même
c'est particulier quoi
non mais certes surtout la troisième
rangée on peut coulisser quoi
un jour on a une magnifique position
puis on prend j'imagine faut prendre en
français 6
e
F3 il faut prendre 5 tours français 6
j'ai pas envie de m'enflammer encore Fab
on en a on a eu tellement on est vécu
tellement de désillusions face à Hikaru
que trois points ça suffit pas pour le
moment à notre bonheur
j'ai en train de me dire une petite
ligne là qui faisait plaisir ça te
repensais 6 des 4 qui pareil hyper fort
on a peut-être des des dames c'est quoi
trop truc comme ça et prends
aussi et on lui bouffe des deux à la fin
donc on a pas mal de petites lignes
comme ça avec qui joue sur les thèmes là
sur les cases blanches affaibli
mais après disons rien d'étonnant hein
des pièces pas protégées ça demande à se
prendre des tactiques ok oui et grand
maître XM c'est cool je fais plus
confiance Martias parce qu'à l'époque au
courant du problème mvl elle mettait 55
ans avant le match contre Sarine j'ai
abandonné l'intelligence artificielle je
pense qu'elle doit avoir un bug
non mais bon 55 contre Sarine bon ok
enfin faut arrêter un moment donné c'est
une version
expérimentale c'est très expérimental
smartphone 55 ans mvel Sarine j'ai
éteint le programme en fait c'est merci
au revoir
c'est complexe quand même
mais ouais je pense que c'est le c'est
le problème mvl un peu
ok
[Musique]
bon
ok menace peut-être décape là pour le
coup
pour le coup pour embrouiller je veux
dire c'est
attention là il va il est en train de
faire sa petite sa petite soupe à eau
est-ce que
bon d'un coup qui serait normal plus ou
moins c'est Dame des trois peut-être
qu'il va nous sacrifier la qualité ou
bon après il y a que une dame qui se
retourne c'est pas non plus
mais ce qui peut avoir la sacrifier la
qualité en fait
je pense pas enfin je pense pas qu'on
prenne aussi c'est à la fin parce qu'il
y aura un objet Cannes et puis on fait
des fins et puis on revient tout couvrir
quoi donc
md3 je sais pas si il veut en fait du
coup la turbinette dit qu'il veut
tourner 8 ok mais bon bah au moins on
s'est viré du clouage je préfère
et peut-être qu'à valider des quatre à
ce moment là
attendez enfin problème ou pas mais oui
en fait il a décidé juste de jouer la
première ligne de l'ordi Maxime à chaque
coup il est impressionnant donc ça c'est
fou prends fou prends
c'est complexe quand même première ligne
de l'ordi c'est fou prend F4 tours F4 et
Dame des trois en fait c'est
j'ai l'impression que c'est bien joué de
la part du carreau là cette partie
plutôt pas mal de mettre une petite
pression mais bon bref quatre on a bien
envie quand même lui ce qui avait dit et
qui rôde une
dame des trois bon pas sûr qu'il le joue
mais en même temps pourquoi pas mesdames
des trois ce qui est pas mal c'est qu'en
fait tu t'enlèves tous les problèmes à
base de tout reprendre et compagnie tu
replaces ta dame qui a fait son temps
c'est le coup que moi j'avais Dame des
sets de base parce que tu fais une
double attaque
plus on le style
malheureusement pour moi
j'ai souvent des petites séries de coups
de Maxime mais le problème c'est quand
tu joues comme Maxime il faut les avoir
en entier parce que sinon ça
va parce que sinon en fait tu te fais
contrer et moi j'en ai genre trois sur
quatre quoi c'est enfin
mais
oui en fait ouais ce sera après tout 8
tu vois moi après tout va vite genre
envoyer du E6
pour faire tour C8 mais je me dis que ça
doit être
ça doit être la faute en fait aussi
la très bonne promo
F3 quel prend F3 tours froid puis on
prend les trois tu as l'impression de
mater mais on a tous vite mat en premier
nous aussi des maths donc si sur dame 7
il y a pas de il y a pas de réponse qui
prend tout reprendre dans ces cas-là
c'est quand même Punto et en plus ça
t'ouvre toute la septième rangée pour
aller mater
ok c'est pris
mais quoi alors on va où c'est bien joué
ça je pense on va à 3 non pour
stabiliser Macron
[Musique]
c'est
la meilleure partie du match pour le
moment ça joue vraiment bien en même
temps
c'est une belle passe d'armes
il va en D6 donc il y aura toujours pas
le double sacrifice en F3 parce que pour
ces tours C7
et si on le fait avec fou.3 qui est 3
tours F3 pour essayer sur Tours C8
d'avoir dame F2 et c'est connu attention
mais pour avoir la draw est-ce que ça ça
peut passer pour Hikaru je pense que
dame me suit ses chèques et on couvre
avec une Toronto
ouais à la fin ouais et on menacera tour
C8
ça a l'air d'aller aussi à noter un très
important Maxime qui sait garder une
minute 38 c'est juste le bon tempo ce
qui fait ça lui laisse vraiment une
minute pour pour avoir le temps de
couvrir après alors il Caro qui continue
à jouer à faire slime
bon de toute façon
ouais
F7 juste pour ceux qui pensent que
c'était possible nous là je pensais
[Musique]
un CD en fait mais moi aussi et sur dame
C5 seul coup qui sera jamais joué parce
qu'il faut prendre le 5
et c'est quoi le problème 4
donc c'est 8 x 8 était obligé de sac
ouais bon tu es pas très bien avec les
Blancs
tu vas sûrement faire ça ça et c'est
même mieux
[Musique]
F7 ouais pour tout RAV4 tout Tour Eiffel
mais c'est trop hein ce qu'il a fait car
oui il a fait full first line en défense
bien joué de sa part
en fait
mais bon si même en faisant ça gagne pas
c'est bon signe
ok
je pensais que il y avait rien mais
ok est-ce qu'on
après si on fait tour C3 et qui fait
[__] le 5 on Adam G8
donc si on fait tour 6 C3 dame D1 roh H2
ou ton 1C3 dame bien roi H2 et damage 5
damasha
mais on fera tout H3 alors
[Musique]
on est quasimat
c'est pour ça qu'ils vont en G2 il faut
prendre le sein qui veut tourger 3
et franchement
le level de la game
ok bien joué Maxime ah ouais là Maxime
il m'avait prévenu aussi ah non il le
fait pas
il m'a dit je joue le temps à fond il
m'a dit je fais tous les pires trucs là
contre contre
dès que possible il m'a dit attends toi
si je peux lui répéter lui faire jouer
10 minutes une position complètement
nulle je vais faire mais j'aurais fait
compte personne d'autre mais ok contre
un tel
ok bon ça c'est répertoire
il aurait pu mais après je pense qu'il
était plus sûr de
[Musique]
comme c'est pas lui qui faisait l'échec
en fait et qui pouvait répéter je pense
qu'il a pas voulu donner un demi point
c'est en jouant à la dernière seconde un
truc sans que ça ait fait les trois fois
c'est ça ouais donc je pense qu'il a pas
il a pas voulu risquer Maxime
bon allez faut continuer
[Musique]
un truc normal que je voulais dire
mais là au moins c'est pas c'est pas un
truc avec le cavalier sur le côté ou je
sais pas enfin ouais c'est une position
d'échec quoi c'est normal ici
donc après cette partie ce sera la
première pause du match à la mi-temps le
Water break Fab la playsters
j'ai toujours
du mal à savoir en fait
elle dure un certain temps en tout cas
Maxime au centre c'est bien il va OK
ouais donc situation
bon d'habitude on voit ça couleur
inversée bon disons Maxime va essayer
d'attaquer à la loi et carreau de gagner
le pont C5
donc peut-être avec les Blancs
d'ailleurs pour stabiliser x 3 qui avait
les A4 etc
donc c'est pas clair stratégiquement
parlant
c'est compliqué Maxime qui prend qui
prend le temps qui veut bien peser le
pour et le contre
je trouve ça pas
idiot au moins pour les cadeaux de jouer
ça parce qu'en fait Maxime c'est pas
vraiment un genre de cas donc tu lui
fais jouer une position de D4 avec un
temps de moins
ou donc carreau devrait être plus à
l'aise au moins un peu plus à l'aise
quoi
il joue vraiment à 100 % icarbonate il a
essayé de d'un peu prendre Maxime pour
un pour un Belin pour un pour un peintre
pour un mariole pour pour un pitre pour
un JAMBON Fab je sais pas si tu en as
d'autres
il y en a plein mais ouais et en tout
cas en tout cas il a bien été obligé de
se raviser le joueur américain
mais comme dirait Murt à ça tu sais mon
entraîneur il disait quand tu fais ça tu
es obligé de gagner par contre après
si tu as voulu prendre ton adversaire
pour un abruti comme la fille car oui tu
gagnes pas c'est ouais c'est grave en
fait donc là il se met une pression
enfin si c'était Mortas son coach il
aurait une énorme pression là tu as plus
le droit après
un petit fou
un paillasson pour une meringue
non le chat il pour une saucisse
pour une pompe à vélo pour une trompette
pour un guignol
pour une éponge
pour un fruit confit il y en a des beaux
notre terroir a de belles expressions
pour un fruit confit
elle est jolie celle-là
pour une buse
en tout cas il envoie le pion h le H
justement
position est vraiment très compliqué
fable cavalier H8 qui va pouvoir revenir
en jeu mais dommage de pas pouvoir le
voir revenir vers B6
là il va être obligé de faire un peu
l'extérieur
ni menace peut-être déjà pions et
prendre ses 5
ouais bon du coup peut-être faudra faire
des quatre mais on n'a pas à mega envie
mais
c'est pas de gaieté de cœur Fab quand
j'auraies
ok il reste plus que que deux minutes là
Maxime c'est une partie difficile pour
lui
mais après oui c'est peut-être pas si
grave de perdre ses cinq enfin
opposés etc et puis ce pion h6 il peut
aussi se retrouver faible c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a beaucoup de jeux à l'aile à
l'eldame il se peut que cette tour soit
obligé de venir intervenir elle aussi de
ce côté-là et ça permettra à Maxime
d'aller croquer en ce pion H6 un petit
peu trop avancé dans dans le camp
adverse
3 minutes 30 contre 2 10 mais c'est la
première partie que qui carut domine en
tout cas Fab dans ce match oui en termes
de la pendule et la pression je pense
que j'imagine que les noms va être mieux
ouais ouais les blancs les blancs les
blancs ici on l'avantage
ça c'est clair et évident
mais c'est pas un avantage décisif c'est
un peu les avantages que Maxime a eu
dans les quatre premières parties il en
a converti 3 Maxime des parties
avantages et une a laissé qu'un demi
point donc il a même pas même pas laissé
de contre là c'est saïkarou maintenant
de faire le jeu et d'aller mettre le
point de son côté et c'est Maxime qui va
qui est dans la peau du chasseur et non
plus du chasser ici il faut prendre des
six dames prends des 6 cavaliers C5 il
va vouloir doubler les tours elle est
loin d'être gagne pour Ikaru comme tu le
disais il y a les rock opposés il y a ce
pion H6 qui peut être faible un jour ou
l'autre
il y a quand même des pièces qui se
ramènent et maintenant on peut avoir des
positions qui peuvent être dans des
esprits alors ça ressemble pas
visuellement mais dans l'esprit des
nages d'orf un peu en quelque sorte vous
allez recomposer et tu pousses comme
oh bah il va amener son cahier des 6 en
baissant et
puis je sais pas on rôde quoi on sait
pas on va voir ce qui se passe
sur un truc comme cavalier C3 qui est B5
car il prend des 5 car il y a 3 échecs
tu as plus de 15 pour le roi tu te fais
dans tous les cas manger la dame sur
l'échec
après ce que
[Musique]
il a pas l'air bien il car ou pour moi
alors dis à plus 0,7 mais c'est l'ordi
smarts à mon avis il va pas être bien
l'ordi dans deux trois coups mais il y a
peut-être dame B2 moi qui me gêne un peu
mais bon faut prendre un 4 quand même
il fait ça alors est-ce que kb5 ou
juste un coup
est-ce qu'on peut faire est-ce qu'on
peut faire
c'est ce que j'aurais fait en partie
mais bon
c'est ce que j'aurais joué 100% sûr mais
c'est peut-être complètement nul
mais ce pion h6 il fait mal en fait avec
la dame en baie de je l'avais pas
j'avais pas vu que vu sous cet angle
enfin
mais on suit
là on
il peut être après il peut faire pion
prend cavalier B5 aussi dame B2
à ce moment-là
la jouer aussi comme ça mais c'est la
même idée en fait d'essayer de de faire
ce qu'on peut mettre la dame
surtout de bloquer cette diagonale en
fait de pas laisser les blancs rentrer
je pense que c'est un point de vue
pratique c'est très bien joué de la part
de Maxime
peut-être rêve 4
et puis on croise les doigts
ah joli cavalier prend B5 qui veut dame
prend mes deux tours
il y a toujours une idée pour Maxime on
le connaît le loustique
il y a toujours un petit truc en plus
mais bon
une 36 contre 44 secondes allez on n'est
pas favori essayez de voleur demi point
par-ci par-là
pour ces deux salaires bien joué
donc là
ça gagnerait pas ça gagnera un pion quoi
enfin ça échanger les pièces pardon
[Musique]
de plus
ça entérinerait un bel avantage quoi
ouais mais le problème c'est qu'il y a
trop de variantes en plus on se prend
des dames j'ai 7 et chaque EMAT à la fin
bah je crois qu'on doit changer ses
dames a priori j'ai peur qu'on va se
retrouver un truc comme tout repenser 3
te repensais trois dame prends ces trois
C3 qui est français 3 et le fait comme
ça OK
G5 pour essayer d'avoir des dames prends
H6 un jour
il a plus de temps maximum
[Musique]
bon après oui bon maintenant là c'est
plus c'est
entre les mains quoi
qui doit normalement terminer cette
partie et revenir à deux points
malheureusement pour nous
la pose arrive un tout petit peu trop
tard mais elle est plus 40 secondes
c'est ton jamais après gagner une
première partie c'est jamais facile
enfin bon même quand on s'appelle
icarbonate à force de pas gagner au bout
d'un moment on se met à douter c'est un
peu comme dans d'autres domaines de la
vie quand ça quand ça marche pas tu tu
te mater
et là il doute peut-être
mais il force d'âme prend B2 c'est
horrible on n'a pas le choix il va
mettre le four en B5 je suppose
c'est la tour qui rentre sur la 7e il
tente pour deux
c'est relativement bien tenté
Maxime qui qui joue le bateau
ah mais les tours qui vont rentrer sur
la sur la 7e
c'est trop dur le sandwiches
après je pense qu'il joue la meilleure
défense possible maximum de son côté
donc ça c'est quand même positif c'est
des matchs de longue haleine donc
faut faire travailler faut faire à tout
non il a raté il y avait tout revient
fou prend B3 tu reprends le 7
et maintenant il est plus
je crois qu'il a vu qu'il a vu un
posteriori
ah c'est terrible
il était un rien de la voir
le hashtag je vais rentrer c'était le
moment le moment important il aurait pu
tenter il y avait cavalida échec mais ça
il aurait pas joué il aurait fait croire
ses deux je pense
des un roi C2 tours 8 G8
ça marchait pas mais c'est pas sûr qu'il
ait trouvé avec 13 secondes
parce que froisser deux c'était fou pour
B3 on reprend B3 tu reprends des 6 tu
reprends le 7
mais le H3 il fait semblant d'être
dégoûté de gagner ouais il est bah ils
sont insupportable on les connaît Fab
donc c'est la première petite pause du
match Maxime qui tourne à 3,5 j'ai envie
de dire un score qui reflète quand même
le match
non mais c'est très bien très bon début
de match bah frère faut maintenir ce
niveau de jeu et puis on verra ça suffit
mais en tout cas on peut pas demander
mieux on peut pas demander plus pour le
moment
Maxime qui qui fait le maximum qui
réalise un très bon début
Hikaru
qui a quand même été solide d'aller
chercher cette victoire même si on sent
une petite cette petite Corée dans le
jeu est quand même rassurante ça veut
dire qu'il est pas
invincible le joueur américain il est
pas clinique ce soir
mais on décrit ça fait plaisir de voir
Maxime mener et oui complètement
il va peut-être dans le noir ouais je
sais pas si tu as une lumière Fab pour
éclairer ouais pour éclairer
tu disais Fab j'ai
dure combien de temps je sais pas j'ai
jamais l'info mais pas très longtemps
ils disent 10 minutes non mais
d'habitude c'est pas 10 minutes c'est
les pauses de
entre les 7 là qui dure dans les 10
minutes
ça doit être un peu plus court attends
je vais aller voir
sur le live officiel mon Fab
alors que je le rappelle normalement
vendredi suivez-moi sur Twitter pour
avoir la confirmation de l'horaire mais
on sera ensemble pour suivre ensemble
justement on sera ensemble pour suivre
ensemble la finale de du speedchait
champion chip en espérant ne pas suivre
Ikaru contre Carlsen mais bien les deux
meilleurs joueurs du monde nvl contre
Carlson qui serait l'affiche rêver
on a espoir
on l'espère ouais ce serait quand même
une plus belle affiche
le match qui va reprendre
rapidement je vais aller sur Live
officiel pour voir oh non ils essaient
de me remettre dans la boucle clash
royale avec la pub clash royale Fab
à tout moment je renvoie une game ils
essaient de me mettre dans la boucle
ils veulent te parler il te parle des
Valkyries
il parle des des cochons
c'est terrible parle de sorcière de la
nuit
il reste plus que plus de 3 minutes de
pause Fab
bon il faut se remettre et puis on verra
faut récupérer l'énergie
sur cette storeso limo peut-être
je passe une troisième fois peut-être
que Max peut réviser à la pause en tout
cas je crois qu'on a vu icaru sur
l'ordinateur révisé de son côté
il va renvoyer son G5 G4 de toute façon
après il peut jouer ok si il veut jouer
qui est 62 il peut mais il peut aussi
[Musique]
comment dire à ne pas jouer forcément
j'ai 63 quoi
on verra décision va être prise à Fab
alors Paris carou pendant cette pause
et
je passe ici un peu le rugby et le rugby
je veux pas te
non mais bon tu vois je m'attendais pas
sur l'Uruguay la colle à l'Italie quoi
ils sont pas fameux quoi
mais bon mais il y a c'est quoi le score
il reste combien de temps
et il reste il reste il reste du temps
mais bon c'est la deuxième Hydra a
commencé quoi quand même
c'est pas terrible
[Musique]
quand même
c'est trop sinon
oh mais du coup c'est peut-être moins
inquiétant que prévu entre guillemets le
dernier match de la France
ouais c'est inquiète encore
c'est quand même inquiétant
je suis quand même inquiet le Fab je
suis inquiet
du coup 17-14 je crois transformation
réussie par
la minute apparemment
bon
ça va reprendre Maxime qui a l'air
déterminé toutes les semaines au score
il nous offre un beau spectacle
on est pas bien
après le chat est plus animé ce soir que
pour les autres matchs
de speechestre
sont venus un peu au rendez-vous
on est que 4000 donc c'est pas non plus
la grande affluence mais bon on est loin
de moins de succès cette année pour le
speechers que par le passé non ouais
mais faut dire aussi que les tournois
s'enchaînent pas forcément bien placé
dans ce dans ce calendrier et le
spectacle n'était pas forcément au
rendez-vous sur les matchs jusqu'à
présent peut-être que d'avoir tout
densifier dans ce mois de septembre
c'est un peu trop trop rapproché
un peu des matchs à un moment et puis un
peu après puis cette prenait quelques
mois tu sentais monter le truc
ah ouais mais bon après il faut il faut
dire aussi que on s'en retourne dans la
route solimo mais pas le G6 hein comme
tu avais prévu aussi dire que la la
saison les tournois il y en a tout le
temps maintenant il y a même plusieurs
tournois en même temps tellement il y en
a
[Musique]
un avion pour aller jouer de temps en
même temps enfin c'est juste tu choisis
ton tournoi tu joues pas tout à la fois
enfin il y a suffisamment de genre
d'échec pour que pour qu'on joue des
tournois et qu'on se dispatche quoi
enfin je comprends pas l'intérieur de
toi remettre les mêmes partout tout le
temps ouais ouais mais c'est écoute Fab
c'est un autre c'est un autre un autre
problème dont on ne trouvera pas les
clés la solution ce soir malheureusement
je sais pas quoi dire quoi il y a
vraiment les échecs c'est une dingue en
fait il y a pas la saison elle est c'est
n'importe quoi en fait c'est compliqué
bon alors il a joué le fond E3 il va
mettre le Cavaillon des deux
mais on a cette paire de fous et donc
sur les éléments cette année à demander
un et ils mettent le F3 et puis essayer
de faire des quatre un moment ou bon tu
vois quoi c'est un truc solide quoi pas
un gros avantage blanc mais plutôt
avantageux quand même un petit peu quoi
et
[Musique]
jouer dans d'ailleurs comme tu le fais
pour se gagner la casser ça
c'est normal bah de toute façon il te
tape ces trois tu le fais
pas maintenant il le fera peut-être
après mais bon voilà ok il a fait
maintenant c'est plus ou moins le plan
normal et OK
damasin qui tape Adam des deux il veut
quoi il veut plus on prend bien prendre
prise
exactement donc pas d'âme des deux quoi
ce que c'est dur il y a peut-être
torrent dans mes deux Damak ouais je
sais pas
non je sais pas ce qui gagne mais il y a
un truc qui gagne a priori on peut
réfléchir
je vais torcer 8 ok peut-être Tourer non
et j'imagine enfin
peu importe peu importe
c'est pas facile de se on sent qu'on est
bien avec les blancs mais c'est une
nouvelle fois pas simple de trouver les
coups non non mais là disons oui Caro il
a arrêté
des parties et
il y a rien de mal à ce qu'il a fait
quoi c'est pas comme les autres parties
avant on voyait que ça allait pas quoi
la première partie ça allait pas les
autres animaux ça allait pas
là c'est ok c'est
juste ça ou quoi il met le fou en C4 je
pense que c'est bien fait je me demande
s'il a pas parfois des fois non plus je
vais essayer de faire c'est fou pour un
F7 cavalier 5 dame B3 et
là non un cavalier B6 ça peut plus
marcher
bien jouécabé 6h
bien joué il fait [__]
ok moi je disais que ça marchait pas
mais en fait là il a dame B3 il a passé
4 à cause de dame prend B6
et sur roi E8 il veut quoi il va vouloir
dame G8
et puis
je sais pas quoi je me disais c'est
juste pour bloquer le roi et après qu'il
y avait les G5 maths c'est bien joué de
la part de Maxime
et Caro qui rend la pièce immédiatement
ah ça faisait trop peur
mais c'est quand même plus en plus pour
pour Maxime
il récupère l'option parce que ça me
prend à 5 il faut prendre à 5 la tour
reste sous pression cependant tu
commences par tout redeen
et qui prend B6 tu prends B6 tu
réattaque C3 et tu vas pouvoir bouffer
C4
c'était pas le coup de leur dire juste
pour
pour te rappeler quand même deux trois
bases bref 7 c'est c'était le coup
humain pas de bol de la turbine
montrerait pas du tout
pas de chance pour le chat
qui a quand même une manie de me prendre
pour un belino un level Fab c'est
incroyable ils me prennent pour un
jambonneau
pense que j'ai aucun coup en fait c'est
trop
vite
ils ont sué la France cette phase mais
il revient sur la pelouse je pense que
c'est bon signe pour Maxime maintenant
il me prennent pour un fruit confit me
freine pour un kaki
confiture c'est bien joué la maxime qui
tape
bah écoute si on mange ce pion c'est 4
c'est très bon quoi
ok oui
il reste de 30 pourri carreau ça y est
Maxime qui revient un peu autant après
j'étais un peu inquiet au début de la
partie infabe avec ce
tiempo qui était qui était tombé bien
vite côté Maxime en dessous des deux
minutes mais ça va il a bien redressé la
barre et maintenant c'est Caro qui est
en difficulté
ils vont pouvoir peut-être me changer la
son avatar
son déguisement de Superman
se prend peut-être un petit peu trop
sérieux hikao Maxime qui est en train de
le renvoyer sur terre la cryptonite a
été trouvée par le champion français
il a moins de temps que Maxime reprends
les devants pour Maxime refaire un
reprendre un petit matelas d'écart
et oui Stan tu dis c'est la cryptonique
là ouais c'est joli jeu de mots dans le
chat allez il faut pas trop prendre la
confiance les amis le match est
difficile notre champion
encore forte à faire il a qu'un pion de
plus dans cette partie elle est loin
d'être gagnée
à ce genre de position qui reste entre
les deux comme dirait Baky c'est 50% nul
50% victoire ce genre de position Fab
ce sont pour son victoire allez on va
écouter les mots du coach
coach qui sort un nouveau livre
d'ailleurs
je pense un beau livre en almanach nous
sort qui nous ce que nous sort le Fab
avec une information sur les échecs par
jour et franchement il y a des choses à
apprendre alors là vraiment pour tout
niveau livre qui sera possible de lire
de débutant jusqu'à vraiment tout le
monde en fait moi j'ai pris beaucoup de
plaisir à le relire
ouais bon chaque jour de l'année il y
aura quelque chose soit une anecdote
soit un joueur célèbre soit mon
anniversaire des trucs comme ça ou une
partie je veux ce jour-là qui était qui
était qui était jolie une partie
historique ou un petit exercice ou un
petit mot alors ça serait plus pour pour
les genres débutants ça mais tu vois on
voit souvent dans le chat ils te dis
tiens enfin ils écoutent les
commentaires c'est quoi truc et voilà
donc ça sera un peu dispatché au gré du
livre enfin du livre du calendrier on va
dire Google je sais pas comment
l'appelait mais mais voilà donc en plus
gagner un jour l'an prochain il y aura
366 infos et d'après ce que je sais il y
a aussi une grobe mythique qui analysait
Fabien dans ce livre
attention tu reprends à 6 Fab pendant
qu'on discute de bouquins il y a ecaru
qui qui a donné un deuxième pion mais
qui s'est activé
il y a pas de coup de tour pour
s'activer à cause des maths du couloir
attention et sur G3 tu reprends le 4 il
y aura des fous rangés 3 qui vont roder
ça va c'est jouer par Maxime
tour de trop enfin il va falloir réussir
à blinder c'est ce qui va faire à mon
avis et après essayer de monter à tour
de de logique aussi c'est bien joué
ouais parce que tu reprends tout reprend
tour de
trois bon mais on mettra le Fouquet
pareil
[Musique]
carreau il nous bloque sur case blanche
mais là oui là il est dans cet élément
là il défend bien en fait mais bon ok
alors il va falloir tenter ça maintenant
alors on va voir un problème quand on va
passer en Détroit
ça le problème en fait
ah il a peut-être oh quelle grosse
défense OK
OK
ouais
en fait ça le problème aussi
il y avait pas les fous ce serait plus
facile à travailler non
mais il espère
ok il va mettre le pion en G5 je suppose
ouais puis peut-être un moment et c'est
tapé G6 mais bon
[Musique]
H4 et sur fossette G5 et après revenir
à rebrousse poil là un peu oui
F5 sur G5
ouais pour C2 j'aime bien
on sait bien il joue des coups quoi
il joue il joue des couilles il fait
jouer des coups
ok il a réussi à passer la tour derrière
c'est plutôt une réussite quand même
mais peut-être que là il va bloquer
maintenant
on a essayé ce qu'on a pu mais bon c'est
pas passé c'est pas passé quoi
ouais bon il essaye quand même encore il
a son pied en plus
nul nul quoi
il y a pas de temps
[Musique]
ouais j'ai pas trop la rêve de ce qu'il
fait
l'autre mais bon c'est lui qui a fait le
blocage maintenant mais
ouais attention quand même
bref c'est pour ça que quand je te
disais il faut peut-être faire mieux je
sais pas je sentais la merde en fait
voilà je commence un peu à paniquer Fab
je commence à paniquer dur là
ou pas
mais élémentaire quoi élémentaire
là par contre ça doit être nul
[Musique]
enfin c'est nul objectivement mais il
faut surtout qu'il faut rentrer en la
finale d'option il y a quelques secondes
dans la partie c'est fou aussi hein
parce que c'était vraiment élémentaire
et en plus il jouait pour ça quand tu
cloudou c'est que tu veux changer avant
et il va quand même la gagner parce que
Maxime a refait non c'est ça
si je comprends bien
de toute façon elle est dure à défendre
avec du temps ça va si tu connais mais
[__] avec 3 secondes
il va juste pas y arriver
[Musique]
je crois
ah non c'est dommage
bah c'est vraiment donner un pion un
point pour rien
mais bon
ce qu'il a raté incroyable à partir
oh c'est trop ah c'est beaucoup trop de
raté filet d'or ouais bon ça c'est il y
a 300 ans ça avait déjà le faire en
France aux États-Unis un peu de retard à
chaque fois l'allumage
là c'était il y a une série de gafs
Hikaru qui rit mais bon
il y a une zone
il fait des trucs un coup tu connais pas
vraiment
ok je sais pas quelle est l'idée en fait
le jeu comme ça avec le blanc
ça craque complètement il y a des essais
dans tous les sens on a 33 17
on va voir ce que Maxime nous fait faut
pas qu'il fasse comme l'Uruguay
justement comme Maxime un beau début de
match et une craquage après
[Musique]
mais ça m'a l'air chaud quoi il va te
faire à 3 B4
peut-être peut-être un peu grisé par par
le bas de la partie précédente
ça se trouve c'est très jouable pour les
normes mais juste je trouve que les
Blancs ont quand même a priori plus de
chance de voir la position que l'inverse
mais on va voir alors il reste combien
de temps attends à faire un petit un
petit point il reste il reste 19 minutes
donc il doit rester deux ou trois
parties dans cette cadence et après on
aura une pause on passera aux trois plus
simples moi j'enverrai 500 trop
réfléchir F5 aussi ouais
fort aussi
mais doit hésiter entre fous français 5
et prendre en E4 intermédiaire
c'est que le match est très très long
il prend
donc peut-être des quatre avec les Noirs
5 peut-être pour le cavalier
mais je peux quand même des cadres avec
les Blancs
peut-être
c'est compliqué là comme position c'est
hyper compliqué
je peux pas faire à 6 à 5 fois 7 il va
faire x 3 c'est ça donc 7 tu peux faire
mais je veux dire oui clairement je
pensais que c'était les coups blancs
ouais donc OK
on est en train de se faire visser c'est
ça
un peu ouais il va nous faire mal
qui G6 en fait tu es moins bien que pour
faire G5 quoi
la partie écarte à de la part de Maxime
et tenter cavalier
[Musique]
peut-être
ouais
[Musique]
il recommence à faire le malin là
elle fait très très mal tu imagines avec
le début de match de folie qu'on a eu
revient à un point
et ouais
mais ok là faut ça en fait tant pis au
pire nul je sais pas faut pas faut pas
se prendre le bouillon et une grotte
j'ai pas aimé en fait
volé et qu'il a
donc il change de ligne il fait 3
maintenant et je crois qu'ils ont pour
jouer le G5
[Musique]
est-ce qu'il y a quand même le faire ou
pas
[Musique]
ce Hikaru il a un supportable là quand
il fait ça
il adore ce moquer de ses adversaires
quand même c'est trop
mais bon il est fort il peut se le
permettre
pour les caméras
il vit pour les caméras
non classique
donc ok plus proche de ce qu'on connaît
dans les Espagnols au 400 quoi
ça convient bien Maxime
ouais
plutôt pas mal
il a choisi
quatre aussi il va jouer quoi à 3 B4
après
ouais bon en fait tu peux jouer de
partout mais oui plutôt là-bas je pense
maintenant il va faire G6 qui est G7
piscine
c'est pas très grave
mais bon avec les Noirs pas si mal ouais
B3 je pense c'est logique tu fais pas et
peut-être te faire vivre des Français 4
et B5 qui est des 4 ce que je fais
penser aussi pour bloquer le cavalier
G7 et
et il va préparer F5
en fait je pense que l'ordi est bien
aimant je sais pas j'ai pas les balles
mais moi je ce genre de question que en
fait bon
mon histoire avec les stagnante j'aime
bien jouer
après
c'est provoquer du FK passer le fond en
deux faire qui va aller h2g4 tu vois
essayer de ah non mais il y a rien
d'inquiétant enfin c'est juste moi qui
aime bien
[Musique]
ou pas mais
pas
il fait tellement le malin sur la caméra
ça me rend fou
bon petit peu déjà fait
alors il fait tomber d'abord
une position pas simple non pas simple
parce que c'est
on a pas trop de plan
peut-être faire foudre bien trois B4 un
moment mais
bon les Noirs
une position qui convient icaru
non il a pas fait
il fait 5 quand même ok bon qui est
logique
et
de comprendre
la caisse de 4
donc vous avez parlé Vlad
rien
ça devient pas con
mais bon ça dépend les jours quoi
[Musique]
prends maintenant ok
maintenant plus tard
ouais non mais voilà on est pas trop
bien quoi
[Musique]
qui passe super bon signe mais il y a
rien de trop grave encore mais bon la
dynamique est plus très bonne quoi
il prend intermédiaire mais heureusement
il reprend la tour en vélo il a une
pièce de plus et ouais bon ok c'est
abandonnable quoi comme position
après Maxime je trouve qu'il abandonne
trop vite quoi faut laisser il faut
jouer un peu la pendule faut jouer un
peu la montre quoi
hop pour souffler
[Musique]
je sais pas
il fait autre chose
bon ben il est dans son schéma de
gonfeld on va dire donc là il est pas il
est pas perdu dans leur position
peut-être et changer
sur casse blanche
c'est dur
j'ai l'impression que Maxime il a plus
aucune position qui lui convient après
carreaux au début du match c'est vrai
qu'il faisait un peu dans les ouvertures
complètement
mais bon je suis content qu'il était
puni un jour comme ça c'est juste pour
pour les échecs quoi non non
certainement mais là là on sent que
quand il est dans ses schémas Maxim il
subit beaucoup
faut pas imposer c'est pas si tient le
choc c'était très bien parti il a un peu
moins mais oui bon là c'est sûr personne
là passe derrière et il faut bien mettre
les barbecues
il faut réussir à stopper l'hémorragie
ouais mais finalement c'est marrant
c'est sur cette position qu'il a défendu
miraculeusement Maxime surtout qu'il
était mieux de base et j'ai l'impression
qu'il a une baisse de concentration
je sais pas pourquoi j'ai senti qu'il
faut le faire nul en fait ouais et puis
tu du coup il a sauvé après tu as
l'impression que c'est ça là il s'est
dit bon j'ai 120 points et je sais pas
si c'est il envoyait une partie un peu
bizarre au noir avec le grand rock il a
arrêté de serrer le jeu et au blanc
partie précédente c'était pas top non
plus
bon après une ça peut arriver ouais mais
faut pas en faire plus quoi
faut vraiment faut vraiment serrer la
vis
ce qui est B4 non c'est pas
je crois pas
il va faire d'un Massac
ça va là je pense qu'il rejoue une
partie
normale sérieuse ouais
elle est un Massac ça paraît bien joué
là il refait une bonne game
vous pouvez donner de Ark cavalier B4
qui doit gagner
[Musique]
il a peut-être perdu déjà non on est
content si je regarde OPI on prend un
train avec la tour
et au pire je sais pas si on a pas mieux
mais bon c'est déjà bien
bon alors
il fait 4
et tu veux quoi
attends je vais regarder
terrible
[Musique]
on est très bien tu peux même prendre
AMF je prendrai pas en fait
j'ai la colonne c'est j'ai l'impression
de plus c'est bien enfin Marion
à trois il va te faire un coup de
Guignol genre fou B5 après la faire du
cavalier G5 enfin c'est je serai déjà en
fait de pas de raison d'autoriser ça
trop bien quoi
non non je prendrai à trois aussi mais
c'est bien la maxime qui se repose
faire qu'il repose son jeu
il prend un F2
mais
n'oublions pas non plus Fab que nous on
a peur parce qu'on est nul enfin je peux
inclure dans cette nullité
[Musique]
s quand même
je comprends pas ou alors il veut un
coup de cœur
[Musique]
d'envoyer ça c'est pas nous qui avons eu
le courage
c'est même pas que de la flemme de
calculer c'est que ça me semble
tellement stable tu as un vrai pion de
plus sur la colonne C enfin c'est cool
quoi tu peux gagner que ta main là bon
la main va pas suffire
mais ouais
après pour avoir souvent discute avec
Maxime quand tu joues top top comme ça
tu es aussi obligé d'un peu de jouer à
la limite parce qu'ils sont tellement
bon en défense
il fait tout Français
F7 bon ça va être un coup qu'il faut
regarder
par contre celle-là si Maxime la paire
elle va faire très très mal
bon après c'est compliqué je sais pas ce
que ce qu'on peut faire cailleux 5
est-ce que
la tour à 4
je voulais faire des coups intérieur de
merde
[Musique]
mais si on peut pas faire mieux on peut
pas faire mieux
c'est trop
de cadeaux là il a fait trop de cadeaux
même si peut-être c'est le meilleur
objectif
stable enfin nous on aurait tout de
suite fait l'autre sans réfléchir trop
peur
et après je suis sûr qu'en cadence lente
il fait qu'elle prend la vidéo est
calcule tout et c'est bon mais là le
problème c'est que bon reste limité dans
le temps donc un moment tu le découvre
vite et c'est hyper compliqué pour
toujours être parfait sur le film une
position comme ça surtout contre Caro
qui est un peu le maître en la matière
bon elle est pas perdue il faut essayer
de sauver ce qui est sauvable et d'un B2
il y avait tout rêve d'eux ça le
problème
il faut s'accrocher
faut s'accrocher aux branches
il faut s'accrocher au branche
[Musique]
qui calcule d'un point des 7 hors C8 qui
est G7 peut-être un truc comme ça tourne
8 et je sais pas moi
allez un peu de réussite pour Maxime là
ça va être la dernière de cette cadence
sur la pose après pour récupérer
ton A5 4 ce serait quand même vraiment
cruel par rapport
au scénario de match
ça très très vite hein
et le fait qu'il y ait pas de pause
entre les parties quand tu as la tête
sous l'eau allez c'est pour ça quand il
a perdu il aurait peut-être fallu juste
temporiser tu vois les trois minutes bah
la première des deux qui a perdu là fait
ton point à 7 pas abandonné rapidement
tu vois
[Musique]
tu peux dire bon c'est pas très
respectueux et tout je le fais pas ça je
peux comprendre là qu'on tricaru
ça passe cette tapas ce problème là en
plus c'est pas parce que c'est que tu
gères ton match enfin
tu as le droit enfin tu as du temps tu
utilises comme tu veux quoi
ouais dame prend des 7 jouets
ok donc ouais c'était le on imaginait
hésitation du carreaux
Maxime qui tente beaucoup il joue Thor
C3
Dame des trois dame B2 et dame G7 quoi
tu vois et c'est OK G5 pas mal je veux
le mettre
faut jouer un coup quoi
t'aurais fait pourquoi pas j'ai envie de
te dire qu'il y avait les FC 3g8 ou C4
on aura toujours tout reprend
ce qui m'inquiète un peu
6 à l'heure c'est le coup
mais peut-être qu'il veut tours c'est 6
qui peut prendre la nul évidemment en
répétant
il le fait pas Maxime
il a joué ça
ça risque de gagner pour les blancs non
faut bloquer le patient
[Musique]
quand même qui tient un peu les cases
une nuée d'échec
joue hyper bien là il change les dames
ok
H4 je pense
pas jusqu'en H2 le pion il veut le
garder là ouais ok il veut il veut stunt
en fait je crois que
c'est pas sûr
ouais mais il part pour le après
je crois qu'il est sur la mauvaise case
avec le roi
ah c'est trop
ah c'est
pas de bol c'est vraiment pas de bol
ouais
juste pour savoir est-ce qu'on est
obligé enfin là on peut pas juste
garder le ranger 6 et rien faire
c'est lui qui joue le lien en fait
cavalier bouge roi vient j'ai 5 c'est
quasiment toi qui peut je passe sur le
fait tout de suite mais genre il y a que
les Noirs qui peuvent gagner ça
ah non
ça peut aller dans tous les sens mais
juste là c'est bizarre qu'il est pas
fait ça pour faire nul
de gagner ça mais ouais peut-être que
Maxime il a beaucoup plus de confiance
que nous que ça en fait c'est nul
instantané parce que si tu fais le même
truc je pense que là c'est ça je pense
c'est trop risqué là pour
ça c'est trop risqué pour les blancs
c'est la même mais en pire
en plus là c'est horrible tu fais nul
même genre le pire coup ça fait nul
aussi quoi
genre vraiment tout fait nul quoi c'est
horrible
c'est ça
ouais ça m'est bien le seum là quand
même
bon mais ouais bah du coup on est pas
trop bien quoi
on était à plus trois on tourne à moins
1 et
c'est le meilleur cadence
sans papiers
3 + 1 ça va aussi bon
voilà ça dégoûte
tu caches pas que ça dégoûte là
surtout qu'il fait un gros début de
match et là la dernière c'est pas mérité
ouais bon
c'est pas fini c'est pas fait 5 4 il y a
un point d'écart
non non
de match
c'est chiant mais c'est comme ça
maintenant faut ok c'est la pause au
même moment tu peux souffler être
prendre faire un truc et puis y aller
quoi on repars tombe battant quoi on a
les blancs on était du mettre la tête
sous l'eau et on continue quoi
ok oui il faut essayer de repartir sans
gros battant comme tu le dis Fab c'est
pas fini évidemment avec un point
d'écart c'est juste que sur le scénario
ça partait tellement bien
et il y a cette partie il y a quatre
quatre et demi et demi ou
il a l'avantage l'alpion de plus comme
tu l'essaye un peu de la forcer il a
sauve avec un peu de bol et après ça il
en perd trois d'affilée
il faut quand même lutter
surtout que les matchs sont longs ça
peut encore tourner même en 1 + 1 il y a
beaucoup de choses qui peuvent se passer
mais il faut pas
faut pas couler quoi
[Musique]
c'est un long combat quoi
on va voir on va voir
rien n'est encore perdu évidemment
il gagne la prochaine partie revient à
égalité
ça serait bien
ça
repartirait sur une nouvelle cadence et
au moment il faut casser cette dynamique
quoi ouais il faut la casser même pas un
moment donné il faut la casser tout de
suite Fab
non non
ça va pas du tout quoi
ça continue dans le même
de tourisme à carré il est vraiment fort
il est vraiment très fort
s
ouais bah il est censé être plus fort
mais après c'est on voit que c'est quand
même très serré dans le
dans le jeu
moi les parties elles sont
elles sont
rien quoi
on va dire mais bon et mais bon ça peut
jouer souvent comme ça en fait où ça se
loue ça joue ça joue puis à la fin n'est
plus trop de temps et ça clique et que
justement les chaos est bon
quand il y a 10 secondes chacun quoi
faut reconnaître qu'il a été très fort
pour comprendre que la finale d'option
gagné même si visuellement tu penses
qu'elle est mieux mais de quand même
très vite rentré dedans quoi
on va voir on va voir comment Maxime
réussit à à gérer la deuxième partie de
match dans tous les cas c'est c'est
positif ce speechasse et ces dernières
semaines de Maxime on voit qui qui
rejoue quand même bien
et évidemment on rappelle que l'échéance
principale pour pour le joueur français
et pour Hikaru aussi en cette fin de
saison sera évidemment le grand Swiss à
la fin du mois d'octobre début du mois
de novembre qui sera le dernier tournoi
qualificatif pour pour les candidats et
qui seront pour pour les deux hommes que
vous voyez le l'objectif principal de de
ce dernier trimestre de compétition et à
la fin aussi de la saison en décembre on
aura le championnat du monde de Blitz
c'est rapide qui sont évidemment l'autre
objectif de cette fin de saison dans
tous les cas les résultats de Maxime
depuis un mois laisse présager du
meilleur
pour ce qui vient il reste 2 minutes 30
de pause et on espère que Maxime va
réussir à revenir fort évidemment à
revenir dans ce match
et
juste une question ouais pour les
conseils aussi une place donc
qui est donné pour le meilleur au
classement enfin la race on va dire
ouais au classement des tournois mais
bon là pour que l'homme personne ne
comprend rien ok ça sera difficile de ça
il y aura aussi une place à l'eau à
laquelle les caroube peut prétendre
alors qu'on a perdu Fab
on a perdu Fab
on va le on va le retrouver
on va le retrouver on va attendre qu'ils
reviennent on a perdu une manière
soudaine
on le retrouve
qui a sauté mais si tu peux nous
remettre à ta caméra le F
ce serait avec plaisir
de retour tu as rien rater Fab
non je me doute mais j'ai loupé ton
explication sur la race et tout ça
j'étais en train de te dire qu'on savait
pas vraiment en fait que c'est compliqué
j'en sais rien
c'est comme souvent dans les échecs
on sait pas en fait c'est trop trop
complexe les règles sont trop complexes
pour pour être compréhensible
c'est trop dur
bah il faut serrer les dents resserrer
le jeu
au moins garder ce match serré avoir une
chance aussi en belette pourquoi pas
qui est plus de 30 secondes de pause Fab
et ça va repartir
en force
allez quoi
ce serait beau
et maintenant les échecs c'est compliqué
à suivre même des gens chevronnés comme
comme Fabien libyevski et moi on
n'arrive pas vraiment à comprendre
allez ça repart Maxime qui a les pièces
blanches alors est-ce qu'il va rejouer 5
et ce qui va tenter le fousser 4
peut-être Fab 1 ouais d'accord on va
voir ce qu'il a ce qu'il a dessus bon tu
peux jouer ici ce qui est F6 enfin ce
que tu veux je sais pas quel sixième il
veut jouer sur des quatre en fait donc
forcément
je vais avec dams et 7 OK
je vais tout rien donc la cadence a
changé
tu as l'air de connaître Fab cette
ouverture
donc il a joué 5 pour éviter les
problèmes en H2
bon en fait moi je vais avoir plus ou
moins genre position mais je vais pas je
crois que je vais Détroit avant
ça change un peu et je conserver mon fou
c'est intéressant et prendre à me
prendre et prendre 5 dame j'ai 3
j'imagine
[Musique]
voilà bon tu es cloué
bon ok
bien sûr tu as donné un pion centrale
faut voir mais le développement dehors
sera pas si simple
donc on va voir j'imagine il veut faire
assis
même à 6 déjà tu pourrais même regarder
à 6 fois 4 quoi F4 je pense pas que ça
marche plus on prend le 5 c'est ça pas
marché mais c'est des trucs qui
pourraient théoriquement marcher quoi
pour dire le danger de la position
mais donc le truc tu peux bien blinder
[Musique]
on va devoir aller en B3 ça c'est donc
en fin le piond peut bouger et renforcer
si besoin par la suite
du coup je vais en vacances je connais
pas la théorie de la position je peux
pas te dire si à cette convention pas je
vois que c'est visuellement intéressant
mais je sais pas objectivement quoi
pas pour ouvrir un F5 peut-être qui
arrivera par la suite alors peut-être
pas tout de suite vu que ça échange les
dames mais
mais
tu peux commencer par cavaler des 5
tirer sur la diagonale tu fais F5 après
moi j'aime bien les blancs mais bon
après parce qu'on aime bien l'activité
intuitivement mais si ça marche pas ça
marche pas par contre ça peut
ouais
en fait c'est juste que ça joue
[Musique]
après il y a avantage autant quand même
parce que là comme c'est plus 5 + 5 tu
es tout de suite tout de suite sous la
minute et la position est quand même
très dangereuse pour les Noirs tu peux
pas sortir le fou facilement il y a de
me prendre G7
mais du coup ton pion aussi c'est
affaibli on menace quand même fou France
ah on menace pas encore mais on aurait
pu menacer
[Musique]
et dominer via E5
c'est pas mal ça c'est pas mal
ah c'est plus que pas mal en fait
ça gagne juste en fait
là c'est un peu la soupe à la grimace la
soupape ça
[Musique]
qu'il a raison d'essayer de faire ça
Maxime perso
mettre la tour en H5 et sur des six à
tourner
[Musique]
en fait
peut-être le faire maintenant
en fait il attendait
ce qu'on est content qui est plus qu'une
tour enfin de plus avoir de retour et je
pense que oui parce qu'en fait regarde
on met le fond en trois
maintenant
on va au dodo
regarde on met ça le pion en B3 après le
fond des trois le roi en E3 et je pense
que on bloque tous les chéquiers en fait
je pense qu'on peut se stand là
juste
bah ça peut
même j'imagine ça va j'ai trois spots
[Musique]
en fait il va tenter
5 pour les 8
on peut quand même faire
au pire fou prend H5 non
H5 je sais pas
j'aime pas ce qu'a fait Maxime là
c'est moi qui va risque d'avancer
c'est pas mal pensé mais bon de toute
façon il peut faire tourner 8
mais il va revenir en C4 avec le fou non
je pense que ça doit être nul mais
pas se prendre un truc à un moment où ça
tourne mal et que d'un coup il
s'infiltre
la fois 8 3
il va partir en H6 j'imagine
pour l'instant il progresse pas mais
avec le fou mais le truc c'est que le
temps
il fait ça
ferme
tu dois partir en
d'autres
[Musique]
ok je sais pas faut regarder mais oui en
pratique c'est chiant quoi mais bon
[Musique]
si on avait joué avec le pion G3 il nous
a H4 on fait toujours faire G4 et garder
notre setup là avec le roi E3 et faire
froid fouder en fait bref trois fois
deux fois deux fois
[Musique]
échec je sais pas c'est de passer par F4
un jour ou rentrer la tour dans une
sorte de zucks
je sais pas enfin
quoi qu'il en soit
je peux pas répondre sans réfléchir le
moment
et encore est-ce que je pourrais
répondre même comme ça
fait depuis le moment là on a sauvé la
nul
ça fait trop on se fait trop l'effet de
film ça fait quatre défaites en fait
pas loin et d'être très loin quoi
et puis surtout que là pour une fois le
match avait vraiment bien commencé donc
on a un peu eu le droit au bonheur quoi
mais en fait pas du tout
dur
ouais c'est un peu la clim
allez gagner une partie en plus après
elle était chaude quoi en réalité
mal tourné
mais après je sais pas
il était mieux ou pas en tout cas la
position était intéressante mais
ouais
la position était intéressante
non deux points c'est pas dramatique
c'est plus le la dynamique qui est
inquiétante le score en soit
pas trop
bon après sa position est très bien je
trouve
très bien il y a pas de problème il y a
pas de problème avec les Noirs c'est
bien faudrait qu'il trouve une arme avec
les blancs en fait
ça mais bon il y a plein de lignes
dessus quoi une autre
gagnant dans l'ouverture hein mais bon
après
je connais pas je peux pas dire mais
juste la position est prometteuse quoi
intéressante mais je sais pas comment je
sais pas trop congé
là je pense qu'on menace
[Musique]
retrouver un peu de la lampe un peu de
la confiance
allez maximiser pas loin dans ce match
allez si l'on gagne deux on retrouve la
confiance en ces deux ton C3 tu reprends
il veut carrément empêcher que ouais
c'est bien joué surtout ces trois il y
avait cavalier B4
ce qui va pouvoir la travailler celle-là
peut-être OK
[Musique]
B4 en face
qu'est-ce que c'est bien joué ce qui
vient de faire les carreaux
4 menace de pions en fait tu as mis il
joue tout tempo il me rend il me rend
fou là
mais en plus il joue bien
mais je comprends il va reprendre du roi
pour bloquer le Pione c'est peut-être
mieux jouer
non mais c'est fou à quel niveau il
jouit car ou quand même
H4 c'est ça
en tout cas Maxime il sort une énorme
game
là ça c'est une très très grosse game
on quand même non
parce que un pion quoi
OK
je serai encore une fois par principe
à deux cavaliers C2 il y a tout rachat
quand même mais roi bouge et cavaliers
C3 allez peut-être Fab
il est obligé d'aller en
lever 4 cavaliers C3
pour décaler la tour
cavalier C2 tu peux faire tour C1 allez
ça a l'air bien ça
moi qui est de réseau de maths façon
quand tu fais un dam tu contrôle la case
allez let's go
[Musique]
enfin ça
gagne mais fin allez
un long long passage
bon voilà c'est ressort si vous jouez
sur skin ouverte donc il veut jouer
l'arroseur
de Baki let's go il joue à 3 ok donc
c'est un petit coucou
d'un coup comme ça
il va faire foudre
et puis on verra bien
direct
pourquoi pas
c'est un petit truc tranquille
positionnel
et voilà on va pas le chercher dans les
positions trop tactique comme il veut
tout à l'heure ah ouais il a été un peu
refroidi Maxime
par la puissance il caresse
après c'est un autre type de puissance
si les formulaire les positions comme ça
mais
bon là on voit plus en mode défense que
en mode oui nous contre il nous plante
des tactiques en bout de variante ou
quoi
ouais
dame deux petits raccordé un tranquille
revenir à égalité déjà
puis reprendre l'avantage
fissurer petit à petit la carapace de
l'adversaire Fab c'est l'objectif
ne pas nous faire un dan D7 là un truc
comme ça à se rendre cavalier B6 on en
parle plus normalement c'est pas le
genre mais bon
[Musique]
il va le faire au prochain probablement
il joue tout le temps de manière très
très active c'est bien joué
c'est des seins qui va y avoir F5 comme
tu disais
tout ira forte
mais peut-être tu aurais fait tu sais
pas un truc
justement allez Maxime qui refait une
bonne game
il veut installer un cavalier en G5
éventuellement derrière mettre le
Cavaillon F6 Maxime
rush je suis dit qu'un rouge je sais pas
que j'ai 5 fougères vite
mais bon c'est une petite
concessions qui ressemblent plus au
début de match la femme
[Musique]
là il joue des vrais ouverture oui mais
bon là il a l'air d'être de nouveau un
peu dans les cordes dans les parties ça
va dire qu'il va pas revenir mais il y a
un moment donné là il y a trop deux
trois parties d'affilée ou tu as
l'impression qu'on s'est fait pulvériser
éjecté hors de l'échiquier
il est revenu
mais bon ok c'est déjà une bonne
nouvelle
[Musique]
je pense que ça part en 5 directs
c'est fort
[Musique]
bah tu vas gagner plus récent
oui mais comme tu as perdu h on échange
tout je te change des cinq Étienne enfin
je dois tenir non
moi je suis quand même
oui bon tu vas peut-être la tenir
OK
mais là F4 c'est fort encore
on a l'impression que Maxime a son
niveau max c'est au dessus du karum max
mais le problème c'est Kiko peut jouer
max beaucoup plus longtemps que Maxime
vous allez dire ça me fait pas penser
exactement la même chose
c'est impression que fédé en fait il est
plus fort intrinsèquement mais le truc
c'est qu'en fait
il faut pas jouer on dame prend le 4 non
c'est un pion quand même
OK
[Musique]
normalement c'est la règle de je sais
plus qui là elle est dans le livre de
marine de marine de marine peut-être que
c'est pas sa règle mais en tout cas il
l'a écrit
de très bonne quoi c'est non mais c'est
exactement ce que je dis c'est qu'on a
l'impression que niveau max ouais mais
bon après Maxime c'est sûr qu'en talent
pur c'est c'est au dessus hein après
mais bon il Caroline de ces grandes
forces et on peut pas lui enlever c'est
l'endurance c'est c'est il est il est
incroyable
en fait j'ai une technique peut-être au
niveau de l'endurance pour minimiser la
puissance du carreau je pense qu'il faut
qu'il ait un enfant
allez franchement ça te détruit le
sommeil t'as plus aucune endurance de
rien et peut-être ça peut la faiblir
grandement c'est peut-être la solution
en fait pour batterie Caron speechers
faut qu'il ait un petit ou une petite
voilà en fait ça peut le terminer ah il
va pas être bien Niko
en plus si c'est marié il y a pas
longtemps ouais ouais bon en fait si il
est en fin de carrière et carreau
il est complètement fermé en fait
un bébé dans le dos
il va il va mettre le caille en H8 tu
vois Maxime avec ses cavaliers mais il
va faire F6 ou F5 et repartir
[Musique]
mais c'est très Maxime
on peut pas trop le meilleur setup qu'à
chaque fois ce qu'il y a un shut non
c'est
à chaque fois d'ailleurs mais en fait
une partie on a souffert avec le grand
Locle et ouais
ce qu'on a pas autre chose qui est ici
je sais pas comme je te dis comme je
j'aimerais la position
là Maxime
au moins il a des pièces bien placées
[Musique]
qui gagne plus ça s'arrête de faire de
la grimace ça arrête complètement en
fait enfin il en fait encore mais genre
c'est beaucoup moins insupportable que
quand il gagne
en fait
travailler à l'entraînement pour vivre
pour les caméras quoi c'est de la vraie
grimace
ok bon pas clair la position je sais pas
trop qui est mieux
on y va on le défonce
même pas pu envisager le coup Fab là je
fermerai que ces quatre
absolument pas dégage j'ai l'impression
que tu t'enferme tellement le fou
je suis pas fan du coup mais je sais pas
on verra ouais je comprends ce qu'il
fait ça peut aussi être faible avec kb4
mais
ok j'ai 6 en fait il se foutent les
pions sur la couleur de leurs fous quoi
ouais il veut lui affaiblir le rock
ouais c'est peut-être bien joué j'en
sais rien moi cavalier 5 non
tu mets ce cavalier 3 et qu'on se porte
le cavalier je te fous ta dame
ça a l'air d'aller non
oui oui
F3
ok bon c'est pas sûr de toute façon tu
laisses la place au cavalier G2 et tu
peux te tiens planter en dessin ou
quelque part
mais bon peut-être je fais de la F3 d'un
F7 du coup
c'était trop et Machin mais je sais pas
ça
j'aime pas principe après mais il leur
dit tu vois il donne cavalier ça
c'est dur à voir malheureusement
tu peux l'avoir après quoi bon pour pour
les noirs
ouais qui est pas complètement dénué de
sens tu bloques le cavalier tu veux
bouffer
8 tours 8 tours 20 tu en reprends un
franchement j'aurais pas
ouais tu te dis je garde que Madame
là-bas
[Musique]
ça c'est foutu
mais il y avait tout reprend le 5
ok pourquoi il prend pas le pion
bizarre
dommage 3 bien joué de la part de Maxime
bizarre de pas parfait prise et d'un
point F5 très étrange peut-être une
petite gaffe de la part des carreaux
G7 mais il y a tout rachat encore qui
est fort dame j'ai 4 quand même Nasra de
rentrer en E2 c'est dommage il a un coup
d'avoir cavalier H6 et G4 et de gagner
c'est sûr qu'il va faire tout racheter
hyper compliqué je sais pas ce que
je suis pas trop capable de dire quoi H6
[Musique]
j'avais mais bon rassurez-vous la
turbine donne encore complètement
gagnant pour Max c'était ma tendeur mais
il y a encore des maths de partout ton
jet d'eau il y a taureau
H2
non il trouve pas il a pas trouvé le
lien
il a pas trouvé Maxime
il va pas gagner c'est terrible il a
raté ma tante ah c'est trop
ah c'est trop
facile 20 oui tu sais qu'il y avait tu
le trouves un stand mais tu as envie de
les doubler tes toits après il y avait
d'autres gains mais ouais bon ça
c'est pas passé
elle a quel âge
tu connais la fable
dessus donc
ok oui il y a beaucoup de coups c'est le
principal mais c'est pas forcément le
meilleur malheureusement voilà tu
connais très bien Fab c'est ton domaine
non
mais bon
contrôle les cases j'ai trois-5 il est
pas obligé de faire des 3 bien sûr
tu te développes et pourquoi pas bah tu
connais très bien
changer contre le fousser un jour vu que
c'est ton mauvais fou
ah tu as l'air de tout connaître la
femme
mais là c'est la semaine dernière tu as
tourne un DVD là-dessus
c'est donc toi le second en caché du
carreau
il faut qu'il réussisse Maxime à
maintenir la pression c'est déjà la
dernière partie avant la mi-temps Fab ça
passe à une vitesse
mais bon il y a rien fait c'est juste ça
ou quoi
c'est pas que ce soit mieux les Noirs
mais bon
tu tiens ta case dessin que tu as pas tu
vois enfin tu as des six un peu faible
vite fait mais pas facile à attaquer bon
tout va bien quoi c'est pas juste nul
c'est nul je veux dire juste des gars
les gars
enfin tu joues une partie après mais oui
j'imagine si personne fait trop de
bêtises ça va
on admettant que personne fasse de
Oui-Oui
tout seul quoi je gère ça ça se dirige
genre s'échange un peu tout seul quoi
prise de 4 prise 4 machin tu échange
je sais pas
la partie précédente elle laisse des
regrets quand même repasser devant ça et
mis du baume au coeur ouais
en tout cas maxi nous offre un vrai
combat pour pour sa demi-finale et ses
rennes qui doit être content en Fab
parce que c'est vrai que des beaux
matchs il en a pas eu beaucoup à se
mettre sous la dent
est-ce qu'il y en a eu ce que ça tout
était sens unique non
c'était pas vraiment je sais pas comment
dire
je pense qu'il fait dame prend le 5
Maxime où il fait dame français 6 B3 et
vraiment nul
directement
bon je crois que tout fait nul
dans le jardin professeur
est-ce que tu essayes de garder un peu
les pièces ou tu liquide vraiment enfin
bon c'est nul mais pas de raison de
s'acharner c'est comme ça
tu peux toujours faire C4 pour la virer
la tour des cas tu pourras toujours
faire ces trois pour la virer aussi
mais bon même c'est final égal ça peut
ça peut tourner un moment si il y en a
un qui est over push
je pense que j'allais dire personne va
over pouce et il fait ses cartes alors
c'est pas un couteau vert pousse mais
enfin c'est quand même un pion quoi
alors c'est un pion si on prend ces
quatre tu veux tour B2 ton C3 tu
reprends à deux mais peut-être tomber un
petit peu
après
il doit pas être bien il est pas bien là
il fait un petit nom de la tête oh il
est pas bien
mais ouais tu vois enfin
concentré là pour se dire allez
peut-être qu'il va
un shot qui était pas prévu allez mon
Maxime let's go allez mets le roi en 163
parfait
je sais pas s'il va y aller mais c'est
lui qui essaye en tout cas voilà c'est
plus en plus c'est pion de plus net en
plus la structure elle est elle est
dégueulasse maintenant
OK
[Musique]
peut-être tour à 4 maintenant
c'est logique tout en place
il veut faire ça échanger
[Musique]
de réagir parce que si tu fais un 4 à 5
tours à 4 enfin là je pense juste ouais
donc ça il est obligé ok
mais maintenant pour B5 du coup et pour
eux prend E5
c'est parti et il abandonné écoeuré
carou allez let's go on repasse devant
Fab ah ben là elle fait du bien celle-là
ça sonne bien mais et puis c'est on est
dans un petit cadeau du carreau c'est
pas tous les jours donc on prend et puis
de tourner devant donc du coup max il a
gagné la session 3+1 ouais on est à la
mi-temps du 3 + 1 la fable ok ça marche
comme ça il y a plus de pause qu'avant
en Fab mais ouais non ça a été gagné par
Maxime qui repasse devant
et puis bah c'est la dynamique a changé
c'est bon ça ouais c'est pris parce
qu'on était on est quoi ouais on est on
a démarré à -1 on est passé à -2 après
une première partie ratée et Maxime là
qui qui est sur sur un bon enchaînement
dommage à rater le mateau dans la partie
d'avant mais bon il Caro un peu rendu
l'appareil
le C4 a fait plaisir
trouver de la part de Maxime
le chat important le but juste avant la
mi-temps et surtout que la position
était nulle Hikaru qui
on sait pas pourquoi il s'est mis à part
à essayer de pousser pour pas grand
chose d'ailleurs hyper énervé là il fait
il fait des allers-retours il a l'air
furieux Hikaru
mais bon ok il y a que un point d'écart
il y a rien de faire mais oui qui reste
énervé et qui nous redonne des trucs
tant mieux il faut que Maxime reste
calme qui reste qui reste en forme qui
garde l'énergie
mais pour moi maxime est
quand les deux joueurs niveau max Maxime
pour moi est plus fort après comme on
l'a on l'a dit on le répète si Caro est
capable de jouer à son meilleur niveau
pendant plus longtemps que Maxime donc
c'est un combat à ce niveau-là un petit
peu asymétrique et surtout Fabien il y
aura la grosse incertitude du Bullet où
là par contre ricarud devrait être
meilleur intrinsèquement
ouais mais bon on va voir
mais oui
on sait
j'ai fait un maximum
Maxime
première minute ouais et du coup il a il
a eu le petit notre analyse en fait
il a ouais c'est sûr que quand il met
tout à niveau max max ouais il est
forcément au-dessus mais il a moins de
carreaux c'est la force hein forcément
si tu enlèves la plus grande force de
ton adversaire tu vas être plus fort que
lui enfin c'est aussi normal quoi
tu peux pas
c'est la stabilité et l'endurance et tu
vois
je suis plus fort que toi connard ouais
bon c'est ça marche pas trop comme ça
ça marche pas trop comme ça
il faut qu'il faut qu'il réussisse à
à maintenir son niveau d'énergie surtout
qui lui en reste pour le Bullet parce
que c'est là qui carouvre à produire
l'effort final et c'est là qu'il
faudrait être très très fort pour Maxime
et puis que si on en perd une deux trois
c'est pas grave pas sombré non ça peut
arriver comme tout à l'heure et là
Maxime très bien réagi c'est lui qui lui
met une contrée maintenant
et c'est pas facile c'est pas facile à
faire quand tu
vas reprendre avec les Noirs il a bien
géré les dernières parties il en a une
vraiment dur salut et là je voulais
recomposer là qui a vraiment été un
naufrage mais le reste
oui oui non ça va c'était mieux il Caro
qui sent quand même rester assez
confiant il a l'air déterminé carreau
bon il reste favori du match
ICA ou encore maintenant grâce à à au
belette à la demi-heure de belette à la
fin
mais bon ok enfin
tout est possible
pour l'instant en fait le truc bien
aussi enfin sur le match je veux dire
c'est que il y a pas de point faible
identifié sur une ouverture ou un truc
on se dit merde on s'est tapé dessus là
dessus
pour l'instant la Sicilienne va bien le
KLF 3b3 il peut le faire à tout moment
évidemment mais la fois il a joué avec
G6 et que certains dans une sorte de
grenfels//
il a peu trop de soucis donc pour
l'instant on savait quoi réagir sur sur
ce qui va jouer donc soit il y a une
troisième truc on stocke soit il va
rejoindre un peu la même chose mais
c'est des parties qui jouent c'est pas
des trucs qu'on est moins bien on se
fait agresser
il y a pas vraiment d'espoir le Bullet
ça fait beaucoup trop de différence
alors moi c'est vrai que je trouve que
dans le format tu vois il y aurait 15
minutes de Bullet ça de belette ça
suffirait je trouve que la la place
prédominante comme ça de nos Bullet
c'est c'est un peu dommage
personnellement parce que c'est vrai que
tu vois des matchs tu vois nous on sera
déjà à 3h de commentaires quand on
arrivera la dernière demi-heure de
belette ou finalement c'est la cadence
où il y a le plus de parties
en fait faudrait juste équilibrer le
nombre de parties
enfin je sais pas comment il calcule
leur truc mais
faut regarder les stats combien de temps
après il y en a là il y en a eu 5 il y
en aura 9 9 et 10 sûrement ça fait 9 9
10 mais bon
tu as quatre participants ouais déjà si
ça me paraîtrait beaucoup j'irai 4 tu
vois pour moi le bolet ça doit être un
truc qui départage quoi
des fois absolument que ça dure un
certain nombre de temps c'est ça la
règle
il y avait les sept qui était possible
qu'il y a toujours une bonne idée mais
au cas où tu peux définir à l'avant
3 et 5 ans
mais
trop d'importance pour un truc qui dure
aussi longtemps ça donne trop
d'importance au beurette pour moi je
trouve que tu mettrais 15 minutes tu
vois même déjà 5 6 parties de belette
qui ensuite tu aurais déjà six parties
cinq six parties ce serait déjà beaucoup
de mon point de vue
tu aurais pas trop tarder et de joueurs
sont en place
mais en tout cas c'est le Bullet qui
sera qui sera décisif quoi qu'il en soit
dans ce match là c'est trop serré
personne ne va pouvoir vraiment créer un
écart suffisant pour être à l'abri allez
Maxime
alors
ça fait déjà ça c'était pas trop mal
pour Maxime tout à l'heure
ok repart avec le client G6 donc bon bah
ça doit être normal
il avait il était parti en suite avec
son cavalier
mais une fois que je fais parce que
dans le sens il était reparti pour
réussir
donc
on peut lui donner un pion mais bon ça
va donner de l'activité au blanc
j'en sais rien je sais pas trop quoi
dire donc Maxime prend pas ça me paraît
plus raisonnable mais vu de loin 103
analyser mais après à trois
ça va pas trop après tu vois à 3 tours
D1 tu vois c'est pas la série de coupe
qui m'a le plus impressionné après
Maxime F5 je suis pas sûr non plus
j'ai pas compris là c'est ah d'accord ok
j'ai compris je comprenais pas sinon
les cavaliers
ok donc bon il a donné un pion et pour
les gaz hein j'aime bien ils peuvent
peut-être faire foudre maintenant qu'il
va aller au 7 cavalier F5 fou B6 non non
ça stabilise aussi je sais pas enfin
c'est intéressant moi j'aime bien ce
qu'a fait Maxime
donc ils veulent être récupéré H5 à un
moment mais bon les notes blancs sont
pas mécontents leur structure en place
donc sont pas si inquiets de faire H5
j'imagine non c'est des conditions là
non non pour aller taper de l'autre côté
ouais tu provoques cavalier F3 non ça a
l'air d'être un coup vraiment à côté
là je le vois je regarde la caméra
chaque fois qu'il fait des mauvais coups
pour me faire plaisir
ok mais bon après 5 c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour nous bah maintenant on va
peut-être pouvoir remettre
du porno
tout à fait
[Musique]
8 aussi c'est une idée j'aurais
peut-être c'est pas mal ça te garde ton
C7 sur C8 tu aurais 8
en fait le mettre un peu sous pression
autant je sais pas si on a un truc
concret à faire avec les Noirs là en
tout cas on risque rien donc faut je
pense qu'il voulait être envoyé
là-dessus
j'aime bien ce que fait Maxime
bien autant enfin genre tu as pas besoin
non plus de te presser si l'autre joue
comme une formule 1 laisse le fin
laisse-le faire ça là aussi
on n'est pas
c'est déjà fait OK
OK
je sais pas on peut pas faire mieux que
ça bah je pense mais bon pourquoi pas
genre là de toute façon
on pourra réfléchir peut-être qu'il y a
même moi je voulais essayer de faire
damso des deux dame B3 mais bon c'est un
peu risqué de partir de l'autre côté
mais tu vois pour essayer de me laisser
des fois cinq et Machin mais bon
qui joue pour le gain c'est hyper
étrange pour moi de jouer pour le gain
ici
je prends les Noirs tous les jours aussi
donc ça ok bon très bien
pour un moment peut-être même faire gs6
si on veut que non et ouvrir je sais pas
c'est pas arrivé il revient en C6
d'accord
c'est bon il leur rend fou avec ça
pourquoi il veut pas faire nuit
un peu moins bien
j'ai 6 non allez
on va revenir avec le cavalier on aurait
dit qu'il prend
mais bon
enfin
c'est chaud en tout cas il est un peu
mieux autant maintenant c'est pas énorme
mais ça peut
j'ai quatre taches
j'ai pas trop la rêve tu fais qu'il
prend H6 quand même
il préfère
en vrai mais pourquoi pas enfin je veux
dire ça pas l'air si mal j'aurais bien
bouffer un truc avant sinon j'aurais
jamais fait ça sur ce tempo là mais bon
c'est
je l'aurais pas du tout senti seul avec
les noirs très franchement
mais ouais c'est peut-être super bien
joué
il va faire cavalier 7 ouais
je sais pas c'est j'ai peur là ça me
paraît tellement fou
ouais je sais pas j'arrive pas à
comprendre qui est mieux et pourquoi
il va revenir en deck
maintenant j'ai l'impression qu'il y a
un problème avec le tarif pas à tout
protéger
mais une partie très bizarre
on pouvait pas le bouffer je sais pas
comment ça ça a tourné j'ai pas il y a
un moment la partie m'a complètement
échappé Fab
mais c'est très dommage parce que ouais
non mais il a bien fait Maxime de faire
ce qu'il a fait
[Musique]
pas sûr mais bon après en même temps
c'est pas c'est pas si clair mais
il a pris
quoi il aurait gagné
là ça perd
on suit quoi
mais ouais c'est dommage
c'est dommage mais bon on peut pas
on peut pas reprocher une partie perdue
en jouant vers l'avant quoi c'est ce que
je veux dire non
la partie était vraiment bizarre elle
aurait pu tourner en faveur de Maxime
aussi ça n'a pas été le cas
malheureusement
ok bizarre
[Musique]
je suppose
mais pour le coup je pense qu'il connaît
en plus ouais
[Musique]
tu me diras ce qui a fait Maxime je
j'adore
là tu peux même avoir des C6 qui prend
des cinq
même grand rock ouais
bon j'ai l'impression qu'on est mieux
mais bon après je sais pas
moi je t'aurais dit oui aussi mais je
croyais qu'on avait un pion plus jusqu'à
maintenant mais je sais pas c'est juste
visuel en fait prise d'essai
il fait comment en fait oui il a fait
tout rire
ok
[Musique]
c'est bon
tu veux être tu veux
tu es très bien quoi tu es sûr tu es
très bien allez faut la gagner celle-là
reprendre de l'avance
peut-être pour se casser mais bon on
dirait qu'ils ont pas le droit
il y en a qui ont essayé
et qui ont pas eu de problème
tu peux pas
entre démonter ça se tente
on sait jamais
reprendre l'avantage il reste combien de
temps dans cette cadence je vais jeter
un œil il reste 15 minutes il reste le
petit quart d'heure
allez il faut prendre des trois tours
prend en plus ça permet de doubler
gratuitement
il va y avoir foutran G7 ici
mais bon faut le gagner c'est chiant
c'est une ouverture qui mérite punition
quoi il s'est refait punir
bah oui mais
il s'est refait punir Fab
alors attends faut que je remette le
score en place
bon là il rejoue
c'est pas le même casier à 3 que tout à
l'heure c'est un vrai cavalier à 300
des idées de foo C4 et de cavaliers B5
dès qu'il essaye de faire le mariage
il se fait punir
comme ça s'ils sont tellement forts
j'aime pas en fait j'aime jamais mais
c'était vraiment plus fort de toute
façon
mais bon ok mais une fois que tu as vu
que ça allait vraiment pas pourquoi tu
refais quoi
tu penses qu'il aime bien humilier les
gens en fait
je pense qu'il tire du plaisir quoi
genre de penchant ça
[Musique]
je vois pas vraiment d'autres
explications parce que là une fois que
le match est comme ça entamé et serré
normalement tu le fais pas
mais je pense c'est un plaisir sadique
en fait
c'est un fan du marquis
littérature française
bah après tu as des gens comme ça
bah marque ça par exemple
portant
prise F5 qui va
échanger les dames avant D1 et reprendre
après ou pas moi j'aurais pris
rendez-vous
en tout cas Maxime
Maxime il réfléchit trop pour moi sur ce
coup là
la qualité et des seins je sais pas mais
que ça allait peut-être pas pour pas sur
ça et voilà parce que après la finale
bah écoute ça va
il va pas se retrouver avec un pion de
moins après
ah ouais en fait c'est pour ça qu'il
réfléchissait et il doit vouloir tourbé
cinq ou un truc comme
ah il veut 3 qui prend
ok c'est pour ça qu'il a réfléchi ok
j'ai rien dit il veut cavaler prendre le
3 ici
[Musique]
ça doit passer
c'est 5 ça doit être pas mal
attendez 8 et tu pouvais pas faire
foudre aussi
et c'est juste complètement nul mais moi
j'aurais pris les Noirs quand même parce
que les trois pions ils peuvent se faire
un peu plus s'arrêter par lui et du coup
tu as peut-être une avance un peu plus
facile
par contre il faut qu'il fasse attention
on a parlé du Marquis de Sade il y a
quelques secondes mais faut que faire
attention à la pendule de Foucault aussi
Fab parce qu'il se retrouve pas bien
hein
il vient de rentrer
j'ai trois je pense
on peut pas me dire surprise il veut te
reprendre des deux et tourbé un échec
enfin il est tombé un et
je sais pas
ce qui est sûr c'est que c'est un fou
furieux
c'est un grand malade de faire ça quand
même
au lieu au lieu juste de faire nul
tranquille pourquoi il fait ça en fait
ça marche bravo mais oui ça marche pas
non toujours pareil
en fait Hikaru aurait été mal au temps
ça aurait été pendu l'inversé
je t'aurais dit c'est très bien joué
mais là avec une 40 une 30 d'avance pour
ikerveau s'il faut être vraiment un fou
furieux faut s'appeler Maxime pour faire
ça
OK
j'aime bien ton rêve de Fougères mais
on leur dit d'un avantage blanc pour que
vous sachiez
c'est ce qui va jouer il faut 4 tu
reprends à deux c'est quoi le matos il
va ouais il peut avoir trois pions quand
même il peut prendre à deux H2 donc ça
va à vrai dire
mais à vrai dire de toute façon il est
obligé de vous faire H2
oui oui tu dois pas lui laisser
le roi survécu
ah c'est un peu Maxime là on a un peu
trop fait mais bon après c'est pour ça
qu'on l'aime aussi mais là il réfléchit
trop en plus
qui déchaîne les enfers
et H5
et ça pousse
faut pas laisser les tours rentrer là
faut fermer les colonnes c'est bien joué
de la tourade de Torah de Torah de faut
fermer oh non mais je joue Maxime
pourquoi il joue pas
je sais pas ce qu'il fait là il me fait
flipper
j'aime pas ce qu'il a fait la maxime
ok c'est bien joué pour ces 7
allez faut pousser
le mec qui disparaît mais c'est pas si
grave il a quand même les autres qui
partent
elle est tombée trois tours j'ai trois
alors peut-être
on en a beaucoup là des Punto on en a
beaucoup allez prends ces quatre allez
monte
pousse pousse
allez
en pratique ça non Fab juste si tu dis
pousse fort ça va gagner je pense OK
juste tu gueules pouces ça gagne c'est
la méta pousse
pousse let's go Fab let's go c'est la
méta mon Fab c'est un grand malade
Maxime c'est un fou furieux mais il a
gagné oh il doit pas être bien
non juste tu gueules pousses ça passe oh
il doit regarde il est pas bien oh il a
pas l'air bien ah il a pas l'air bien là
oh il a l'air écœurer mon Fab
trio spa
il doit pas être bien ça fait plus de
notre requin est là
tu imagines la folie de la Watch party
vendredi est-ce que c'est un Maxime
contre Carlson tu es sûr de venir à 100
%
non je suis pas sûr mais écoute je
j'essaierai bien sûr même si c'est
Maxime contre Magnus
un temps pourcentage quand même tu dois
pas être bien ah tu dois pas être bien
ah il est pas bien la femme
non juste tu dis pouces et ça gagne
c'est ça c'est toujours ça c'est avec
les Cantal et puis on passe ça marche
toujours
les pions sont l'âme des échecs
ah désolé femme obligée de se lâche un
petit peu parce que il y a trop de
pression là il faut il faut
mais c'est un grand time
je savais pas qu'il y a autant de gens
existait pour mvl oh bah oui ils sont
normaux les Américains aussi en réalité
dans leur majorité évidemment qui sont
pour Maxime comme tous les gens en
normaux
allez doit être en confiance Maxime
quand même il reste quoi il reste 5
minutes 05 il en reste une ou deux dans
cette cadence plutôt une que deux mais
en bleu mais peut-être que peut-être que
c'est le dur bien elle peut durer il va
envoyer F4 non c'est un grand malade
je pense qu'il casse 4 non enfin
peut-être au pas ce coup-là mais il va
cliquer allez
c'est peut-être pas si grave il va faire
tout trois tours des trois non
j'ai 4
attention à G4 quand même pour toi il
veut faire tourner 6 c'est ça
peut-être faire un F3 un jour quand même
mais bon
il va où le cavalier en fait ça la
question
8 j'imagine
ça ne serait barré avant en fait que
cette pression sur la colonne après il
peut se barrer avec la dame
OK
déjà si on n'est pas moins bien à vrai
dire si on pouvait tempo cette partie et
aller chercher le Bullet en commençant à
plus de on prend
et après ça joue enfin que le meilleur
gars enfin que le meilleur gagne que
Maxime gagne Michael français
[Musique]
on va la chercher quand même
ok ces deux j'aime pour empêcher P4
c'est hyper bien joué oh mais là il est
on est d'accord Fab que là Maxime il
rejoue à son niveau main genre quand il
était champion du monde de Blitz ou pas
mais tu trouves pas genre qu'il est en
train de revenir à un niveau auquel on a
plus vu depuis très longtemps
franchement ça fait combien de temps on
a pas vu Maxime genre aussi fort en fait
il est enfin genre là si il joue sur
échiquier il le défonce en fait il y a
même pas de match
c'est sûr en fait parce que il est
vraiment ça lui donne un petit bœuf
en ligne c'est voilà il est habitué à
jouer comme ça il y a pas de normal quoi
il y a rien de grave mais
en fait c'est fou en fait il est
vraiment plus fort
OK
très bien aussi évidemment mais c'est ok
c'est les top monde là c'est top enfin
c'est les top 3 monde
donc forcément ça joue bien partout quoi
OK
je sais pas c'est bon il va pas tenter
G3 max
c'est risqué parce que là tu as une
puissance très stable tu as pas de
problème tu as plus de dans le match
peut-être pas
[Musique]
je comprends même pas le coup en fait
non plus
[Musique]
oui non mais il va se battre mais
tu es pas ravi d'avoir cette solution
quand tu avais F3 quand G5 il y a deux
coups quoi ouais après peut-être qu'il a
énormément de bol et que c'est pas grave
du tout
enfin c'est peut-être même nuit au blanc
en fait
c'est terrible en fait parce qu'il avait
pas du tout là
j'avais même pas d'idée ok peut-être
c'est quand même pas mieux au blanc
c'est très très relou
bah c'est terrible ce mystique ou cette
gaffe
est-ce qu'il va y avoir encore une
partie derrière ou pas ce serait mieux
qu'il y en ait pas à mon avis ouais
c'est bon c'est la dernière
au moins si Maxime vient à perdre on ira
au Bullet mais je vais aller il aura le
temps de récupérer mentalement ouais
c'est dommage
ça aurait pu très bien tourner
mais bon c'était très dur à trouver
[Musique]
ça et puis bon qu'est-ce que je fais
quoi
OK
et torder ça il faisait comment ouais
c'était tout raciste
en fait
ok bon plus hein écoute c'est bien très
bonne session de trois plus
ok dommage celle-là mais bon peu importe
c'est pas c'est pas une partie à prendre
comme ça c'est l'ensemble a été
excellent et il va falloir bien jouer en
belette donc bien prendre l'énergie
terrestre
bien bien grignoter avant et être
et être au contact tout le temps quoi
évidemment mesdames et messieurs
parce que le Bullet c'est le champion du
monde entier alors sur vrai échiquier ce
serait différent mais mais à la souris
et il est vraiment extrêmement fort je
pense que pour être favori il aurait
fallu être comment ça plus 3 + 4
la plus simple ça va être très difficile
c'est stressant Fab
je sais pas ça peut le faire enfin
évidemment c'est un gros challenge mais
mais c'est bien enfin déjà on est devant
avant cette dernière session et
dans ce que je vois dans le jeu ça va
quoi donc
ça se passe ça se passe très très bien
en terme de niveau de jeu il y a eu un
seul passage à vide dans tout le match
qui au final et pas énorme il a donné on
va dire deux parties sur tout le match
mais bon ça a été un petit peu ennu ça a
été un petit peu
allez faut que maximum ça tout donné
est-ce que là toi tu prendrais genre
full café ou quoi ou tu ferais quoi toi
tu sais que tu as besoin de tenir une
demi-heure de plus tu as non je crois
que le café c'est bien pour la
concentration
donc
genre tu serais capable de prendre
quatre expresso là
mais je sais pas c'est bien mais tu
seras en capacité de le faire quoi
tu serais fou quoi
tel un des paumes
voilà
non mais ouais bien c'est de rater je
sais que c'est bien
café c'est bien voilà
cerveau a besoin d'être hydraté pour
être performant ok oui donc faut boire
de l'eau et puis du café pour la
concentration à fond quoi
et tu cliques comme un fou après quoi
tu es un peu comme Néo dans Matrix
on a l'impression que
que les coups arriver au ralenti
tranquille quoi
c'est un café de voir six sept café par
partie non Yann
mais je sais pas mais oui enfin il a
souvent son truc là il boit à fond ah il
fait que boire du café
en tout cas ça marche quand même plutôt
bien même si il a perdu le match
Championnat du Monde 2 à deux reprises
il a quand même une carrière
déjà fait du monde c'est déjà énorme
quoi donc deux d'affilés et
la dernière fois quand il a dominé
il aurait dû gagner il était à un coup à
plusieurs reprises il est à un coup
d'ailleurs
[Musique]
allez faut que notre Maxime nous offre
une performance majuscule il a progressé
en belette
pour le petit délire marrant il s'est
remis à beaucoup jouer en belette quand
il m'a vu jouer en belette ok donc il
s'est remis à refaire du Bullet il a
l'écran qui est réglé comme il faut la
souris la tout comme il faut
comme il faut des fois il m'a mis 9 et
demi il m'a il m'a roulé dessus mais bon
c'est Hikaru en face ce sera pas moi
malheureusement Fab j'aurai signé là
pour jouer à la place du carreau la fin
de match on aurait été plus tranquille
là
mais je peux te dire qu'il est chaud il
est chaud notre Maxime en belette après
il joue contre bah le Champion du monde
en titre de la cadence là c'est vraiment
lui le plus fort de très loin
normalement un point c'est trop maigre
pour réussir à batterie carou mais un
maximum en grande forme comme il est ce
soir
peut-être réaliser un exploit
en fait là c'est pas un match tu
commences à 0-0 tu as quand même eu une
fatigue avant peut-être des petits
doutes pour les Carouge j'en sais rien
il parle douter j'ai l'impression mais
mais bon tu vois que ça se passe pas
comme ta imaginé
en tout cas c'est sûr qu'il carreau
avant le début du match il pensait pas
il pensait pas être embarqué dans un
match aussi compliqué ça j'en suis j'en
suis certain
il a pas l'air complètement sûr de lui
il fera quand même complètement le malin
de cigale en mode je suis plus fort mais
ce qui est sûr c'est que le doute c'est
ainsi dans sa tête Fab
il y en a certains qui doivent pas être
forcément très bien de voir un autre
Maxime revenir un tel niveau de jeu pour
les échéances importantes à venir de
cette fin d'année mon Fab
on l'attendait plus un Maxime
oh oui et non je sais pas comment dire
le Phoenix
que jamais enterrer un jour pareil non
plus
à l'international non mais même enfin
ils savent que bon tu sais jamais quoi
enfin nous on a toujours su par contre
je peux pas te dire il va tous les
cartonner après ou quoi mais en fait si
Maxime il joue bien sur un tournoi il
peut te le gagner et puis c'est tout
quoi donc que ce soit le grand Suisse
que ce soit une coupe du monde que ce
soit un championnat du monde rapide
oublie
intrinsèquement il est là quoi donc
après c'est plus dans
la stabilité peut-être que c'est pas
facile mais qu'il aille te gagner à ton
appareil
même dans les cinq prochaines années je
veux dire tu vois enfin c'est voilà je
peux pas te dire avant le tournoi qui va
être favori de le faire mais si ça
arrive
c'est pas si surprenant quoi enfin
je mets un petit peu
comme ça bah ouais
un petit tweet
tu as dit quoi
juste avant le Bullet
il faut réussir à
bien commencer sur tous ces belettes
ouais
parce que
plus on peut faire douter
un moment donné c'est pas qui va douter
moi ce dont je rêve c'est que dans 35
minutes il regarde le résultat et qu'ils
comprennent qu'il a perdu
ah mais ça c'est le dénouement mais
avant faut qu'il doute
mais là il a l'air
il a sa tête qui doute hein
il est pas aussi serein que ouais il est
pas là ouais mais déjà il a pas le
casque quand même je pense ça lui fait
mal de pas avoir le casque parce qu'il a
pas sa petite musique son machin où il
peut un peu tournoyer quoi
je suis pas sûr en fait
si tu mets du naps tu es tout de suite
très très bien
c'est carré le S tu vois tu es lâche tu
es dans le Carreras
mais ça que Louis Vuitton tu les payes
en espèces enfin tu vois tu es de
partout quoi forcément ça te donne une
force que que qui peut te manquer quoi
quand même
ouais
qui sait riche devant le Maxime mais
c'est faisable après je dis pas que
c'est fait non plus évidemment mais
ils ont interdit les écouteurs
d'ailleurs aussi ils ont tout interdit
allez on Maxime
donc Max qui va avoir quoi les noirs
pour commencer alors pour commencer
allez lui mettre lui mettre déjà le
bouillon avec les noirs
très dur à dire allez ça part
je sentais pas à venir dans un débat
théorique mais
Maxime qui envoie 5 vidéos
passé sans parquer là dans son enfin pas
assez distancé là de son rythme de folie
réussir à rester dans Maxime allez
cavaliers à 5 il remet un petit
une petite pression d'armes B5 cavalue 7
Roy 8 c'est forcé 10 secondes de retard
ça va c'est pas trop grave pour le
moment les cavaliers qui sont proches du
roi mais Maxime qui réussit Fab à
défendre
échangé le foot Cazarre
tout va très bien allez F5 c'est parfait
il carou qui
ok il y a une grande vitesse d'exécution
ça va pas lui enlever mais après ouais
c'est pas
position
c'est pas grave en vrai
il y a un truc qui s'est mal passé là on
sait pas trop pourquoi il y a des pièces
qui sont agglomérées là proche du roi de
Maxime c'était pas prévu dans le plan
t'aurais évident on fait juste tu aurais
fuite non
on a un peu obligé
j'ai pas trop comment on peut
s'organiser Maxime qui rejoue vite
ah bah là ok on est pas trop bien
surtout pour du bolet en plus j'ai envie
de te dire
je prends
des trois malheurs
en fait il perd pas de pièces mais il
prend F6 qui va arriver et c'est pas
j'allais dire c'était pas encore maths
mais ouais bon c'était perdu toute façon
il karaoké égalise immédiatement
Fab c'est la bonne news
de l'impression elle est bien et je sais
pas d'un coup bon bah oui enfin de toute
façon le belette évidemment ça va être
d'un coup ça va tout va très vite
mais dommage mais si on joue le même
genre position pourquoi pas en fait
enfin on n'a pas été mis en danger dans
l'ouverture et tout allait bien non mais
c'est c'est ça le problème c'est que ça
ça tourne mal et après qu'on tricarou le
truc c'est qu'il fait plus de cadeau en
fait c'est très difficile de faire
tourner une position contre lui
c'est à dire que son son déchet est
minime en belette c'est un de ces points
très fort et on a commencé à le voir
malheureusement à nos dépens notre faute
direct non il fait pas de fautes direct
quasiment jamais
c'est vraiment son jeu
mais il est très fort à ça c'était une
des raisons pour lesquelles il y en a
autant dans ce speechasse mon Fab
Maxime qui se place là j'aime plutôt
bien la position des blancs pour
l'espace mais il y a rien de fait du
tout
je sais pas
est-ce que tu peux essayer
OK
de pousser de l'autre côté ouais c'est
ce qui fait
ouais parce que
quelque part ça évite que ce fou soit
trop trop mauvais
ok là c'est le bordel
il va faire G4 je pense
ça rentre de partout
ouais je sais pas mais c'est vrai que
c'est chiant que Caro ne se trompe pas
trop quoi
il est vraiment fort
tu reprends des trois peut-être
je crois qu'en plus c'était le coup de
l'ordi
aïe aïe aïe
c'est vraiment un problème
on peut l'être c'est vraiment un
problème
bon allez on va essayer de rester
positif il y a qu'un point d'écart
victoire de Maxime ça égalise
24 minutes
et jouer trop vite
Maxime espérons que ce soit pas trop
vite
en plus j'ai l'impression que ouais il a
des il a il a la partie précédente se
passait plutôt bien ça là ça l'a encore
plutôt cool
mais ce qui fait complètement logique et
censé
en fait c'est terrible
en fait
je sais pas quoi enfin
ça dégoûtant
bon allez il a réussi
bon on a perdu le pion quand même en
plus mais bon est-ce que c'est si grave
ouais on se rend les pots de banal de
guignols non-stop
ça rend fou
et c'est vrai qu'il rate pas trop de
tactique en face
[Musique]
mais c'est ça un peu qui saoule dans le
format du speechers en fait c'est que tu
viens de suivre quand même trois heures
et quart de match
et au final le truc le plus important
c'est le truc le plus débile en fait qui
a plus de rapport avec rien je sais pas
ça t'écoute en fait
c'est juste tu as l'impression que ça te
met à la poubelle les 3h30 d'échec que
tu as regardé quoi avant
ça bizarre toi ça te fait marrer mais
je trouve ça a pas trop avec le reste de
ce qu'on a vu en fait
aussi long machin et tout pour qu'en
fait bon bah il y a un point d'écart un
apétizer pour sortir
quoi pour un truc
et disons que j'avais adoré en plus ce
championnat du monde de belette quoi
c'est un admettons à préférer de l'année
que c'était très très drôle mais je veux
dire là je trouve ça un peu bizarre
mais ouais il est il est trop fort
au centre va tenir quand même mais bon
pas gagné quoi
quand même
non mais c'est pas ça la question c'est
pas une question de gagner ou perdre
mais c'est juste que si tu
en fait c'est le match est pas serré bon
bah c'est pas serré donc bon ça change
rien et quand le match est serré du coup
et qu'ils sont intéressants ça se finit
là-dessus et c'est un peu frustrant par
rapport à tout ce que tu as vu avant
quoi
je sais pas ça me paraît logique mais
après
quel dommage
il y a des six
alors peut-être
ça prend des 6 qui est prend B6 ou D8
qui a été 5 et c'est 7 imparable c'est
ça
encore gagné malheureusement mais ça
peut mais c'est bien de la part de
Maxime parce qu'il a voulu
c'était le seul coup il a encore trouvé
ça c'est quand même nul
et donc tous les rats sont bloqués
il est fort
il est hyper fort
comme ça
parce que le roi
[Musique]
pas très loin en fait
mais bon
partie a duré combien de temps et il
attend pour faire tourner la pendule
c'est terrible
OK
ah dommage mais Maxime avec foudé 6 là
il a pas eu de bol parce que
c'est pas payé
allez on va espérer que
que ça passe
allez ça va prendre il va remettre le
four en G6 peut-être
blindé mais c'est solide là
pour
là c'est exactement ce qui se passe
c'est ce qu'il faut pas qu'il se passe
en fait
ça va c'est encore solide mais c'est pas
c'est pas l'idéal
il va essayer de faire passer qui allait
prendre des cinq je suppose
il a fait foutrant cavalier prend allez
il est vraiment pas bien Maxime
c'est bien joué
c'est dur c'est dur parce que c'est dur
de faire des gros écarts en blitz avant
et en fait un avantage qui est
c'est tellement une cadence tu fais plus
d'écart il y a moins de nul en fait
donc logiquement en fait il y a juste
plus d'écart
à un moment
c'est pour ça Carlson
ce qu'il est vraiment fort en belote
aussi
[Musique]
c'est bien joué encore
passer cette muraille sur la 5e
et maintenant il fait ça
est bien placé non
il va avoir le temps de bouffer
ah mais il se fait prendre l'autre pion
des manières de générer
on doit pouvoir stand
je suppose
mais bon ça va redirer sans cause de 300
coups
ça a duré énormément de cool
[Musique]
c'est bien joué après il y a rien à dire
stratégique
et là il a vu qu'il y avait 50 coups
donc il va attendre les 20 secondes
derrière
il va être obligé de faire nulle part
lui-même quoi
dans la gueule quoi
trop
pousse tout
c'est que ça crée une frustration chez
l'adversaire et c'est regarde un maxi il
rate complètement ça partit
ouais terrible terrible Fab ça c'est
séquence de belette
[Musique]
et je crois que ça c'est la partie qui
nous enterre
tu vois quand on a dit qu'il fallait
trois points d'avance en fait il en
fallait plus
on n'a jamais eu de chance en réalité
dans ce match
c'est comme ça Fab
Ikao était plus fort
il y a rien à dire Fab
il était meilleur il était meilleur sur
le match
il y a rien à dire
c'est comme ça il est il a vraiment trop
des carreaux
il peut être devant il peut être un peu
derrière peu importe mais ça va être
serré en fait on se balade il est trop
fort il est trop fort
le Bullet fera la différence en fait
quoi qu'il en soit
et tu vois j'ai l'impression qu'il avait
de la marche pour faire une plus d'écart
en belette
ouais bravo à lui
mais Maxime je pensais bien quand même
qu'il est dominé en blitz parce que
finalement c'est le plus important pour
la suite il y a jamais de Tournon en
belette il se prend maintenant
il y a jamais tourné en belette donc
c'est pas très grave j'ai envie de te
dire
mon Fab
mais c'est
de bonne augure pour pour la fin de
saison
ah bah ça de toute façon le niveau de
jeu dans les dans les matchs précédents
et dans Suède était très bon après le
Bullet c'est un peu différent des échecs
des échecs mais ça montre d'autres
qualités aussi c'est moi le fond c'est
plus du CLIC et
quoi dire bah oui enfin tout ce qu'on
disait de toute façon que ça va être
cool pour pour le pour le comment
s'appelle il Hoffman match tournoi hyper
important voilà qui offre quand même
deux belles places pour les candidats
donc bon bah faut avoir scorer contre
les affaires moins fort
mais voilà format Open donc ça change un
peu de ce qu'on a l'habitude de voir
et puis en fin de saison après justement
rapide et Blitz toujours très
intéressant à suivre pour pour clôturer
l'année quoi ouais qui sera le beau
tournoi comme toujours entre Noël et le
jour de l'an qui donne deux titres de
champion du monde celui de rapide et de
Blitz donc Maxime qui a déjà gagné une
fois le titre de champion du monde de
Blitz et qui va
et qui va jouer pour pour essayer de
reconquérir ce titre mais aussi
peut-être de gagner pour la première
fois un championnat du monde de rapides
il a montré de belles choses quand même
au tata style en Inde
ça peut enfin j'ai tout à l'heure c'est
tu peux pas dire tes favoris avant mais
ça peut arriver quoi
oui oui mais j'arrive Laura il aura il
aura un shot donc c'est des c'est des
très très belles échéances
qui
[Musique]
qui lui fait office de favori pour le
coup mais bon on va pas gagner chaque
année tout quoi
non non c'est pas comme le speech
par contre
étonnant
championnat du monde de Blitz en fait il
y a que deux joueurs dans l'histoire qui
l'ont gagné plus d'une fois
et en plus ils ont gagné plus de deux
fois les deux non donc je sais pas
en fait il y a personne qui va gagner
deux fois non
[Musique]
étonnamment
mais comme tu disais c'est pas un
tournoi facile à gagner il faut vraiment
être fort et
endurant pour le coup c'est quoi c'est
21 ouais et
c'est vrai que c'est au final il a quand
même aussi par rapport au fait qu'il est
dominant il a quand même la porte de
sortie belette qu'il avait sorti là
qu'il a eu servi contre dingleren contre
et dans d'autres matchs c'est vrai que
là c'est du Blitz fur et dur quoi
donc c'est peut-être c'est peut-être
moins
après bon si il est en grande forme il
pourrait hein quand il joue bien en plus
il joue bien mais oui il ira moins ce
côté dominateur qui peut avoir
pas qu'il puisse pas gagner mais
moi à moins dominateur évidemment
s'il y a si c'est exclusivement du Blitz
exactement
on en avait peur dès le début de match
que le mais le score est très très
sévère en belette c'est évidemment une
possibilité moi je pensais qu'il fallait
commencer avec plus 3 + 4 tu vois en
fait le match était peut-être
mais bon en fait là ça suffit pas en
même temps à la fin c'est libre ouais
il y a deux parties ou quand tu as perdu
cet a perdu donc tu as pas envie de
perdre mais bon tu es moins dedans
ouais je pense qu'il aurait fallu plus 4
en fait
ok match
pour qui match
Nico a été d'habitude il n'a pas humilié
bah il a essayé en fait au début et
quand il a vu que ça se passait mal ça
marchait pas il a dû se raviser enfin
qu'il est pas essayé c'est juste que
Maxime a vite vite fermer la porte
et donc on se retrouve à un suivez-moi
sur sur Twitter et je vous donnerai en
suivra ensemble à Paris la finale contre
Magnus qui sera même si Maxime ne sera
pas présent final ce qui est ce qui est
toujours dommage mais ce sera quand même
un beau match quoi qu'il en soit les
deux meilleurs joueurs du monde
en blitz Bullet et ouais c'est quand
même les deux meilleurs
[Musique]
que l'un contre eux en fait il y a
Maxime qui a battu Magnus c'est le sol
je crois
mais qui a un meilleur match pour Maxime
ce qui a justement moins d'écart en
belette entre les deux
mais après Magnus il réussit plus à
tenir
ikaro en belette
en fait je sais que les deux premières
années il a gagné largement ouais après
Magnus a perdu et l'arrêter et l'an
dernier il a perdu en finale c'est ça
ouais aussi mais
[Musique]
donc le match sera de printemps sans ah
il y a pas d'âme c'est un et dames
je vois plus rien non plus
[Musique]
et donc la somme battle qui aura lieu
samedi à 19h n'hésitez pas à m'écrire
sur discord ou vous me trouvez oh joli
ça
Maxime qui applaudi
pour qu'il prend ce qui va le laisser
reste des places dans l'équipe dans
l'équipe belge Maxime très sport
mais ça va être la dernière partie Fab
on vous enverra
vers le stream en anglais pour
aux interviews pour les interviews
bien évidemment
c'est la douche froide ce Bullet de bord
mais là les dernières parties ça change
ça change rien
ça aurait été en tout cas un beau match
que Maxime nous a offert
mais c'est dur de votre au cas où à ce
jeu
c'est très dur
maxime a vraiment fait un très très beau
match
je pense que vous pouvez difficilement
faire mieux en vérité non non mais ok au
pire peut-être tu marques un point de
plus dans les bleus je sais pas ici ou
là mais
malheureusement c'est probablement pas
assez pour éviter la furia du Bullet
pas abandonné là quand même même si il
est perdant
quand tu fais un bon match et que tu
joues
on va se quitter on voit que les joueurs
quittent les caméras pour les interviews
j'envoie le raid à chascom nous on se
retrouvera pour la suite du speed chasse
donc à moi je serai pas sur la chaîne
officielle donc ce sera si vous voulez
passer vous me suivez sur Twitter et
normalement bah vous savez que ça allait
spot à Paris si vous trouvez l'horaire
c'est entrée libre vous savez que vous
pouvez venir et on regardera ensemble le
match contre entre Caro et Carlson pour
la finale et on vous laisse sur les
pages d'interviews pour pour la suite
merci à tous et à vendredi samedi sur
Paris ciao ciao ciao